all right and we
all love the last word with lord cognito
and ibontis and that special
guest and returning third chair
the legendary thai guy travis ign's fire
chat you know what i'm saying good
friend to the campfire before i even
talk to the homie ibontes
travis what is going on with you sarah
how you been man i've been great
mcclunky i'm fresh off of
my 300th episode of fireteam chat
uh and you know we're now no longer
doing that weekly model
but uh it was awesome got to hang out
with some old
cast members talk about destiny and
then i've taken a little bit of break
and here i am talking about destiny on a
friday again so i'm really excited about
this
it's been too long a couple weeks and i
start to build up you need to just
gush about there's a lot of stuff going
on with osiris there's a whole bunch
we'll get into it but we
of course we got my homie the legendary
cheetah
always good to see you my man lord
ibatis what's up man
that was kind of funny i don't even know
how to fall i can't follow that how do
you follow that
random but i liked it by the way that's
not even remotely what a cheetah sounds
like but cool
i will pass that one i tried man
yeah hey you gave it a strong effort
that's totally fine
uh no uh destiny had a big week
in multiple facets of twitter
start of the week with the weekly reset
and everything so a lot of stuff going
on there
i have not been streaming that much
though because i have been building a
murphy bed
and if you guys don't know what that is
go look it up basically it's the beds
that like fold up so it's like a cabinet
and it shipped in like this 500 pound
crate and i've been working on that over
basically my off time and
yeah that's probably if you put together
ikea furniture or anything it's got
nothing
on this this is to a whole other level
this is like four pieces
screws it's got like enough springs to
hold the bed that folds
there are more danger warnings you will
lose a finger this will fall on you and
crush you it's like
you should be using two people i'm doing
this all by myself so it's just like
this is one of those things that's been
um yeah a little
this is one of those where somebody was
like hey i'll handyman do it they would
underestimate it no question so i've
been
neck deep in that but i'm so excited to
talk destiny with you guys because
that's pretty much what i've been doing
in my off time
so i'm going to send it back to you
because we got a fourth person we got a
guest host but we have our guest
of the hour so sir cognito let's bring
him in bring him in
all right welcome to the last word
episode number 156
it's another glorious friday we're back
in front of the campfire for some more
lunar shooter discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest so we're going to get right into
it
i want to introduce the lord whose
passion for the destiny franchise
star wars and all things pop culture can
only be matched by its rise as an actor
and multimedia content creator within
the gaming community
introducing the creator and host of the
ig
neil twitch channel and writer for lords
of gaming.net
the lord of anime fitness and good vibes
and loki the most underrated destiny law
ambassador in the game
live from florida and making his debut
at the campfire of the last
word my man prince delos aka ty swenson
of
lords of gaming.net how we doing sir
ladies gentlemen and envies how you
living
cog man to have you do an intro for me
it's crazy because finding the last word
uh
about a year ago now at this time the
first time i listened to you all and to
be a guest on the show incredibly humble
experience
excited to be with everyone around the
campfire get that destiny talk going
and and you you give me too much credit
and underrated loremaster i appreciate
you though i appreciate that
good discot listen man one thing i look
forward with you is uh doing
when we do lord's minute on
lawrencegaming.net and it's kind of like
a one-on-one
video series that you've been taking a a
good part of and um
i'm talking lord it's bad getting into
this [ __ ] but thesis theories we getting
into it i'm like
oh that was a very fun piece to write
that was a great one when we did with
the crow so yeah
i i tremendous respect for what you're
doing obviously on the team and then
your channel but it's good to have you
at the campfire man with the homies and
talking destiny got a lot of stuff to
talk about but glad you could make it
back for sure
no doubt so we're gonna let you set it
off man you know some questioning
for this gentleman yeah before we get
into some of the
off destiny topics and gaming things um
gotta start out just kind of with the
history of your gaming
kind of how long you've been around the
block like what is your seasoned gamer
pass like
how veteran are you like what where'd
you start what are your what are your
games of favorites over the years
uh so i started my gaming journey on the
sega dreamcast i was a very
very small gamer at the time my parents
got it for me and the first time i never
played yeah and then i grew up the next
day boom
first game i ever played was sonic
adventure one sonic has a special place
in my heart because of it
and um the next game was sonic adventure
2 after that
and i played that game a lot because the
disc tray got stuck to the dreamcast my
parents weren't going to help me open it
back up so i was just stuck playing
sonic
forever
yeah eventually they got me a
playstation 2 i moved on from there
got into some final fantasy
which final fantasy sir i started with
uh final fantasy vii
i played that basically only through
midgard so with um the remake happening
i have no idea what's happening after
this
uh hey you never went back and finished
you and i share something i haven't even
seen mid-yard yet so whenever i go play
on ps5 i'll get a fresh
fresh run too yeah so i'm very excited
for that and
the other main game that got me uh a
special love for this weird franchise
was kingdom hearts
play kingdom hearts on the playstation
2. fell in love with it because i was a
huge
um destiny a disney fan
disney the other d um because at the
time
uh my first trip to disney was as a
make-a-wish kid
so disney was a very special place in my
heart ever since then
and this weird mesh of square enix
characters along with disney
just it was the coolest thing ever to me
at the time though i pretty much played
all the games after that uh
king and mars 3 is kind of how me and my
partner started dating as well
ironically so it's weird how it's
cemented a special place in my life
since then
but of course wanted to xbox 360.
i mean my friends at the time it was
either halo or gears all day halo or
gears halo gears
mass spec three came out mass effect 3
multiplayer halo gears halo gears oh
it was classic yeah we we grinded mass
effect 3 multiplayer a lot
a lot very nice nice nice uh then wrap
things up
this giant white board i can explain it
from you
from a to z what actually happened but
long story short there's a mouse named
mickey
a dog named goofy and donald he's a duck
he never heals you
the end he's goofy adoptive do we know
that for sure
oh you know i would hope so i think
pluto then
pluto is a dog that's less smart i guess
the neanderthal of dogs
that's very scary no offense to any
pluto fans out there
a horrifying world that disney has yeah
i mean maybe if you gave pluto pants
you would then be smart you'd be just
like goofy i'm done with y'all
y'all with this kingdom off because i i
will say this is a ravenous fan base
and like to travis's point like i still
don't know what's going on
but it's funny to me because it's like
but based on what you're saying you know
with your history
i couldn't understand you know at the
time i guess this marriage of you know
the disney property
into this you know cool franchise and
people just going crazy and
but yeah it is a ravenous space man i'll
be eating have you seen
i mean i've honestly never touched
kingdom hearts i've seen obviously you
know like the keyswords i've seen a
little
right the art style for it and
everything but it's always like kingdom
hearts one kingdom
heart kinda carts 2.1 2.5 2.8 and i'm
like after a while i'm like i
i think i've missed this franchise so
i will i will leave it to those who are
neck deep in it and you guys can enjoy
not saying it's bad casual i'm a casual
kingdom hearts fan but i have
no idea what's going on in the story uh
even though i've played them all and i
think most fans are probably like me
uh and and i would say the fans uh
make the destiny community look mild
and like mellow about their game like
you're right
they're they're psychotic about that
franchise
it's a ravenous i want a shot who's on
on the team for long that macho
uh yeah he's hardcore kingdom hearts
obviously addict
but what's funny i give out of critic
like he admits he's like yeah the story
is convoluted
very convoluted no way and the way that
they ended the third game was also
convoluted and mess and
lastly for kingdom hearts it's fine that
i actually don't like the main character
all that much i've been a riku guy
day one and the fact that in that game
they're like yeah riku is actually
supposed to be the keyblade master but
sora
it just made me more mad and then ever
since then i was waiting for the chance
to play riku without using a game shark
shout out to game shark in the plays
and then they would just give you these
like little tastes except for um
two of the the um handheld games the um
chain of memories and then 3d drop
distance where you could
get a good amount of riku gameplay but
they just give you that taste and i was
like just
just give me the whole cake yes let's do
it get up his own series let's go
but another game you had on your list
that i thought was really cool
that not too many people mentioned and
it definitely hit me was um
life is strange oh yeah yeah i was i was
a big like a strange guy so i'm very
curious to see like what drew drew you
into life is strange especially like how
did that's what things started
so when i first played life is strange i
um it was about maybe like a year or two
after it initially came out
i played on the playstation 4 and i
found
that the the game had
a very interesting way of telling a
story me as
a as an empath um i am
really i really gravitate to stories
that can use emotion
a great and tasteful way to make the
uh audience feel something and with life
is strange
i felt they really did a great job on
giving you
enough sense of control on where the
story is going
from point a to point b um and
they had a wonderful core of characters
with
max and chloe that was like the ride or
die
from day one yes um great story
yeah and so i was after i finished it
it was the
i think it was the first game that after
i finished it i just had to sit there
and just
cry because it made it made me feel
something
in a way that a video game hadn't done
before and then
with the the next game that's i have
those as my top two in the series so far
before the storm we go into chloe's
backstory
and what was going on you have to see
how she ended up where she is as
basically
a teen suffering from trauma and i'm
raging out against the world
and made me even more torn up because
in life is strange in my head can't like
max and chloe they're like this they're
they're going out relationship in love
100
and then you introduce chloe's love
interest before max pretty much
and she was basically the definition of
a toxic relationship
she would take advantage of chloe a lot
of the time so
a very interesting i loved those
characters a lot i felt like
don't nod had a great thing with those
two
after that they had still some pretty
good um story beats with life is strange
too
um tell me why i'm very much looking
forward to true colors
but nothing has nothing has yet hit that
greatness that they did
with the max and for those who haven't
played i know
we kind of got deep but you know for
those who haven't played it it's um
it's first of all the music is very well
done oh the soundtrack is basically
right original opening five minutes
i'm in there the music is amazing and i
admit there were about there were about
three or four
key it's kind of like e and e and travis
it's kind of like
they took telltale's formula and just
blew it up and made it so much better
and it's just more
context and you really have emotional
connections with the characters and i i
remember not to spoil but they
i mean i knew the game was real with the
very first scene that
led up to a major scene that depending
on what you did
a character was very suicidal and if you
didn't remember key things to
try to help this character you this
character will lose their life
it was it was you know what i'm talking
about um
that's why i was like yo it made me feel
bad that i wasn't paying attention to
the game
that's like wake up yeah it's like wake
up this game is real
theory is that the the developers they
take the chance
to essentially take a real world issue
and present to the audience and try to
educate on you with every game that they
put out they even have the
hotline um for you to contact if you're
suffering from mental illness or things
like that yeah it's a very very powerful
game but yeah salute to you and i wanted
to
shout that one out but uh try me any
questions for the for the prince
yeah well i've played all the life of
strange games and oh
they're awesome what are you doing i
played all the games come on
[Music]
um
yeah i've played them all um i think
they're good i have some notes
about some of the decisions that they
make in that game but uh we'll talk
about that later because they're kind of
spoilers
yeah but yeah um mike i guess my
question
is um how did uh how did you become
exposed to
bungie or uh i guess the path that led
you to destiny because so far you've not
really mentioned any games that are
uh close to what destiny is right how
you got your foot in the door
there right so i've i've always liked
um rpgs and things of that nature
uh aside from my friend group they
really gravitate a lot of the shooters
besides mass effect mass effect was the
closest thing that had a lot of heavy
rpg elements and of course we played
halo
um bungie's previous glory days i
started out
with um halo 2 into halo 3. i played a
little bit halo 2
and then really got into halo 3 with my
friends um
and for how we how i got into destiny
for
destiny 1 we were at a random convention
and we had
um played uh the beta
that they had they had a game room set
up to where they had a beta available
for
uh anyone to play and
everyone's like yo we should get this
and they were talking like who's class
who's gonna be which class
and i was deciding between either the
hunter
or the warlock at the time um but then
my friend was like
uh oh yo i'm gonna be hunter so
you gotta be warlock i was like well you
got all right that's fine
magic i was kind of getting like the
force fives with star wars and things
like that so i'm fine with warlock
so we played destiny together played it
through the campaign
and after that they pretty much fell off
and went on to the next game and i was
by myself and i was like all right i
guess this is it so before
first raid vlog even came out i was like
all right we're done we did not
look back destiny 2 comes around and
they come back oh you remember that game
we used to play yo they got a sequel we
should check it out
so we jumped back in reported over our
characters i was like mind blown about
that i was so happy the only thing is
that my hairstyle was different
that bothered me because i had like a
pixie cut cloud strife look
and then it gave me like a super saiyan
mohawk i was like okay that's fine
um so but again we played it through the
campaign and we actually
made it through the first raid um
leviathan
and we got through got through to
um dogs and never finished that raid
i don't know what happened but they fell
off and and then
i was like that was a wrap um and i kept
it
i kept the game on my hard drive uh
it will be like years later when
forsaken came out
i personally jumped back in by myself be
forsaken
played it a little bit but at the time i
didn't put myself
out there try to connect with other
gamers because i wasn't really close to
my childhood friends anymore so i didn't
really have anyone i was playing with
so i um put the game back on the shelf
went off to other things
it wouldn't be until like cove it hit
nothing to do
time on time on time that i was like you
know let me let me boot up destiny see
what's happening
so i booted it up season of arrivals
season of arrivals and something about
it just hooked me in
and i said i'm actually going to i'm
committed this time
no matter what one on reddit join the
clan
been in there ever since nice nice the
arrivals that's what's up
yep oh no he's gonna say us for as
you've had this like sporadic
taste of destiny just like little
sampling through the years
how because you did d1 fell off
didn't experience taking king so you
haven't heard these like fantastic
moment one
d2 not the best moment for destiny you
did see a forsaken
and then beyond light hit where where do
you feel beyond light
how did that hit for you because it's
been kind of mixed as we all keep
talking about all this stuff more and
more where expansions fall
where is beyond light where is this year
for you but specifically beyond light
we'll get into the seasons as we get
closer
but how did you arrivals came in beyond
light hit were you like sweet this is
amazing or
where you at right so i had time to
get myself caught up on a pretty
comprehensive
uh footnote for the lore so far
shout out the biff watch a lot of his
videos play of course
played um war mind and curse of osiris
um before it went to the vault and as
things were developing the season and
the pyramids were showing up i was
excited
i was like oh like the darkness is here
um
and uh sun setting was was coming into
being and i wasn't as attached at the
time so i wasn't
as mad about it um because i didn't have
a lot of this
year one year two stuff that i liked
that was gonna get sunset
and then when beyond light hit most of
the stuff that i was still using was
safe from sun setting
um i played through beyond light story i
thought
stasis itself was very interesting um
from the supers and subclasses i had
gotten used to
i enjoyed it from a narrative
perspective a lot that's what had me
sunk in at first i thought aramis was an
intriguing character
and then when the story was over i
kind of felt like like um some people
have already complained about that
you know i was expecting something
bigger to happen as
the dominoes are being set up for the
darkness
to hit our system
he reviewed beyond light so he's he's
definitely nodding his head with
all of this yeah
yeah it was this again it was like kind
of this weird disconnect of where
we were told to be looking one way but
we were essentially
being taken almost in another way like
sure we we
commune with the darkness and we start
using the darkness subclass um
but like ever since then the darkness
has been kind of on the sideline
uh so europa itself i love the planets
beautiful
kind of wish we had some gambit maps or
some pvp maps but that's okay
oh yeah um that's a whole yeah the main
story of destiny has
always been the side story of destiny
like it's it's never the main thing like
beyond light they're like oh yeah this
is all about aramis and then you're like
oh by the way you're becoming best
friends with the darkness and there's
huge implications of that but we'll talk
about that later right
yeah we'll get to it later don't be bad
don't use those powers
if you if you would
remember that please please don't use
the darkness thanks
effective immediately we're going to put
a ban on that i'm going to write a i'm
going to write a sternly worded letter
decide to use the darkness the ghost is
going to go out it's going to go in your
file
i'm going to get a demerit
i feel you man but yeah i hear what you
say it and that it's a good point you
know in reference to
sometimes you know dusty starting with
that you know
the one that they promote the marketed
story right
versus you know saying what actually
happens when you you dig deep into the
end game and stuff like that
but it's interesting because you got
just like he said yeah just like going
in
right yeah i was in and out there for a
second
no doubt no doubt so what would you say
because you did mention
um forsaken right and what out of what
you were in
and available for what were in your
opinion
like peak moments for destiny because
like i said you've been in and out kind
of so i'm just curious for you which was
like
yo this this was a moment like what was
peak
destiny for you basically your
experience let's see peak destiny for me
um i guess coming in of being someone
that's on
that was only partaking partially and
then leaving
um what got me to come back into
forsaken of course was that initial
cinematic of forsaken
and seeing kade
kay taking a bullet and i was like they
didn't really just just
kill kade did they so i was i gotta find
out so i played it
oh they did that they did that um you
did play forsaken
i thought you played d1 vanilla d2
vanilla
and then didn't hop back on until
arrivals is that i'll hop back
on i hop back on in for forsaken
i played through the campaign of
forsaken then i hop back out
didn't even see so
yeah continue before he continues i have
to
i have to tease e a little bit here oh
and find it interesting
right that when you hopped out
you hopped back in and forsaken because
of the marketing
of kade's death so i just found it
interesting because this has been a
point of contention at some point i
shouldn't even say a point i do agree
with e
but what he he really can't stand that
they did that like fritz but he cannot
stand
that they killed him that he wanted that
to be revealed
in the story naturally right and i feel
him
right but i i always felt that the
marketing team
and travis you tell me if you agree like
push that to sell that expansion to get
your credit
and i know that but it's just funny to
me for prince who went away
and the reason he came back is because
he had to know
who did this to his man continue press
continue
yeah i i understand defend myself over
here it's fine keep going
i understand this feeling because like
now being on the inside
i'll be pretty upset too if we get like
this big reveal
spoiled in the cinematic trailer before
actually experiencing the story
but i have to give it to the marketing
team because they got me with that even
if it was only for a little bit they got
me to come in
i swear to god if they kill ikori in a
cinematic for which queen i'm gonna be
livid
that's all i gotta say like e kate had
to die
so that the destiny community could live
he sacrificed all right ob
yoda oh true it's true
so yeah i agree it was totally a
marketing ploy but it worked and was it
worth it right if
destiny was not headed in the right
direction hot on the heels of curse of
osiris
some of the other stuff that came out
after vanilla so was it worth it to kill
off a beloved character so that the
community could come back in force which
it did
and it rebounded with forsaken expansion
and maybe it wouldn't have had that
chance if uh
if they didn't have such a uh evocative
provocative
like tagline of like get revenge revenge
this character that you really love
so absolutely continue practicing you
you say it
um but yeah so that that got me into
forsaken um playing through the story
uh let's see peak mom speak moments so
starting off coming into
destiny 2 because that's what i remember
the most i i barely remember
my time with destiny 1. um destiny 2 the
opening mission on the fall of the tower
i thought that was
really really cool really cool strong
first mission to start out
um one of my favorite moments is when
you lose your light
and you're coming out and you're coming
out out to that cliff side
and that music starts swelling like ah
oh man
he loves it i love moments like that
where the music um
coalesces so well with the scene because
i'm also a big music person my part
partner she has a degree in opera
um so that was also very well done
i think everybody has a an attachment to
that moment
because it was so different from
anything that the destiny
had done up until that point it was like
really really slow
intentionally slow emotional
storytelling i remember so the first
time i played that
was in a hotel because i was doing the
on-site review for destiny 2 and it was
a whole bunch of other journalists who
were seeing it like
you know a month before that it would
come out and that
that night that we got there they're
like all right you're only gonna have
enough time to play the first two
missions and then we'll pick up tomorrow
and so we all played that and i remember
afterward everybody like went into the
halls and was just like
this is this is gonna be awesome like
like this game is great like already it
was just such a great first impression
we were all
i think i slept like two hours that
night because i was just like
eyes wide open so excited to play more
right and i really liked as you went
along the way
how they did with you gaining your light
back with going to the shards of the
traveler
and having those story beats and that
constellation hologram
type form it definitely had me
glued to such an interesting way of
telling
a big important narrative beat of kind
of the history
of the light as it's gone through the
years of destiny
um uh after that the
kind of get get the band deck back
together type of beat
was interesting um
icora icora was something that kind of
stuck with
me for a while because she was a woman
who basically lost her faith
and the way that her journey went from
coming back
to helping at the end i thought was uh
very well done powerful storytelling um
i i can't say that i i enjoyed um
zavala's part too much i've always had a
love-hate relationship with zavala to
begin with
so i'm sorry to say i didn't really i
was all right all right moving on next
um and then uh of course uh kate's was
fun
and yeah and i i really much enjoyed
seeing them without a lot without the
light coming back as we were retaking
the tower
um retaking the traveler at the end that
was a very
very cool moment um leading the charge
uh that's probably the last like high
point for me in the base campaign
the fight with gaul was it was something
i wasn't wasn't the payoff i was
expecting
um and yeah
for for the rest of i didn't really have
any big high points until i essentially
got back into the game got to doing my
first raid
experiencing some other story beats uh
yeah no no doubt no doubt travis any of
the questions for the brits
feel like there's one topic travis has
to at least press him on one or two
questions
right yes i was wondering when would be
my window of opportunity
now is that time how is that we know
it's coming i noticed a little helmet
behind your head
oh oh this little thing over here that's
not from destiny is it where could it be
that's the new warlock you didn't know
about that
definitely a titan helmet yeah i think
we all know that
uh star wars let's talk nerdy to me
uh yeah a few that's people with the
with the keen eye
might know um yeah that's the
mandalorian helmet
hey i got got a clone trooper helmet on
my beanie here
at the soca colors uh we also got some
matching children
in the background
that's amazing well yeah i'm a huge star
wars fan
ever since um i was little i like swords
and
i was like yo i actually need to like
laser stories they just made swords
better so that
nerds have been trying to build them in
real life ever since
the first star wars movie i ever watched
was actually a new hope
um i watched the original trilogy then i
moved to the prequels even though the
prequels were
coming around when i was still little
but i started with the original
went to the prequels and so someone who
likes the prequels because they came out
when you were a question or
a very good question um this is a very
interesting dynamic in the community
because he was born after return of the
jedi he probably really likes that movie
because he doesn't find the ewoks to be
weird but people who came who were
watching star wars before return of the
jedi
think the ewoks ruin return of the jedi
so
i'm on the internet i'm on that that
doesn't mind the ewoks because it came
out after i was born but the prequels
i remember the first time i saw a
phantom menace i was in fifth grade
and it i left the theater and i had this
weird feeling in my
my chest and i was like what is this
feeling and i realize now as an adult
that when you're a kid you love
everything
every experience is amazing and that
walking out of fentanyl was the first
time i had seen something i didn't like
as a kid in my life everything was
amazing and it took me i didn't even
know what it felt
like this is a weird feeling did i just
see a movie that i didn't enjoy
uh but yeah i did i'd like to hear what
do you think about the prequels
um so the prequels i
i never hated the prequels as much as
the well star wars community hates a lot
of stuff but as much as the star wars
community
hated the the prequels um
revenge of the sith is probably still my
favorite star wars movie of all time
whoa and or yeah
it has a great lightsaber fight i'll
give you that that's for damn sure
yourself great lightsaber fight um great
music
that needs explanation for me i'm sorry
okay
i'll be your friend all right all right
so i will tell you i will tell you how
it feels or or revenge of the sith um
by itself not taking into account
anything they added afterward
um to help uh round out the story
is ultimately it does come down to
the last bit of the movie with anakin
versus obi-wan on mustafar
um i don't know it's just something
about that that brotherly love being
shorn right in half that it's cringy and
cliche but i was all there for it like
when he when obi-wan says that he loved
him
i loved him too you felt that you
you know
broke my heart broke i was in there
did you at least get the cosine for the
emotion travis uh i cosigned for the
emotion but i cannot cosign for the
dialogue man the
dialogue is the worst part of the movie
i will give you that i have a theory
about what happened with the prequels
because there's this thing when you're
making a movie they do storyboards
and on the storyboards you write
placeholder text that's not supposed to
be
oh and then they never change that it's
actually in the script yeah it's just
supposed to be
the the the basic idea you want to
convey in that scene and i haven't i
have a theory that george lucas created
the storyboard script
and then they use that as the actual
script in the movie because everybody
was afraid of like
stepping on george lucas's toes because
that all of the lines of dialogue
sound like something that you would
write if you were trying to be like okay
well we want him to say something like
this
not this exactly obviously this general
idea
right and then you know if you're not
with me you're against me like all those
lines or you're just like okay
like there had to be a better way to
write that but they just went with the
storyboard text
that's my theory of for all the prequels
of why the dialogue is so bad
right that's a very good theory yeah i i
don't have a problem with you liking the
the prequels teach their own
i actually don't hate the prequels i
like every star wars i
i like all of the content there's
there's none of it i'm not a hater like
like so many star wars fans are but uh
yeah i mean there's just so many good
star wars movies it's surprising to me
the revenge of the sith is the one that
you you associate with but you know
yeah it's ironic that like i didn't
become a
die-hard star wars fan where besides the
movies i went to like
now i go into the every single tv show i
go into the books i go in the comments
comics anything star wars i'm gonna try
and get my hands on it
and it didn't happen until disney
really took the helm of star wars and it
wasn't because
now that disney was in there i was like
oh disney i'm following them it was just
that
it was a nice reset for me because i
hadn't
um dived and delved into the eu
before that but then with the reset of
the cannon i was like this is going to
be
the best time if i want to know anything
that's actually
matters right now for the star wars
storyline
yeah no that that so i i was one of the
guys who who
kept up with the old canon and he got
out of control because
uh lucas would sell the rights to make
star wars content to anyone with two
nickels to rub the writer and it was
just was out of control there was like
you know palpatine came back seven times
and i think wicked the ewok killed
one of those times like just ridiculous
crap we were like what the hell is going
on and so
i sort of gave up on it but when disney
acquired it and they said everything's
on canonized i was like thank god
because
as a star wars fan it's it it really you
need to control
your your ip and and i just
lucas was a terrible custodian of the
star wars ip so
i definitely i always say i always take
that line that um
or for rise of the skywalker i know it
had
very interesting um final villain but
uh it was a nice nod that somehow
palpatine's back
because that was the story of all every
time for the old cannon palpatine would
come back
through cloning or some means yep and
now it
yeah i remember the old uh wiki for the
pout for palpatine's page it used to say
like
the years that he was alive to the years
he died and then there was like another
set of brackets under that and then
another and another and another like
he was alive from this year to this year
and then also i was just like i
i i hate this and now on the star wars
wiki i'm sure they're gonna have to add
it back
if he was ever really dead i mean yeah
but right i don't remember
for you travis but i'll also say that
for star wars my favorite star wars
character of all time is ahsoka tano
i think that's teddy's as well it's a
good choice it was yours
travis i think mine's yoda yeah i think
that's too they have a lot in common
oh old people oh nobody understands us
we're weak
speaking speaking of weird dialects you
know good stuff right yeah
can't form a language super well well
speaking of keeping your ip in control
there's this
franchise that we've been a hold of for
a few years now and they've actually got
a
job that does this now there's going to
be we're going to roll into the dusty
stuff right now that's the war horse
whatever they literally posted it out
job for destiny historian
you guys see that posting i did yeah
so there i don't i didn't even read
through it you did nice
travis replied um well i was like i
think i saw it first because
i saw bibes tweet that was just like i'm
not touching this
like not even not even my thing not
really qualified for it so
not really jumping in too much
read the job um i got to find it real
fast yeah i'm going to say what it what
is the uh requirement well what is it
that bife thinks he's not qualified
why does bite think he's not qualified
that's great
it must not be what we think about i
think it is he also said that he just
got
married as well and he didn't want to
uproot him okay okay
yeah the responsibilities of
i'm sorry destiny historian
coordinate with the destiny game
director and narrative leads cross
project to ensure consistency and
continuity for destiny
coordinate with internal and external
writers to verify consistency
create and maintain story bibles on
destiny
work with the creative teams to manage
all the logistical aspects of
coordinating destiny and ensuring final
products are consistent with the product
standards
establish style guides and spec reque
specs required to define
and document the narrative direction of
the project
generate and maintain story treatments
character bios
environmental guides casting documents
and other supporting narrative
documentation
maintain character and world consistency
across all storytelling channels cross
project
review all game scripts reads them for
content and continuity
and offer suggestions and feedback when
necessary prepare reference materials
for external partners
uh work with production to manage
schedules
support larger franchises same stuff but
i mean it's
it's all it's basically keeping the
continuity of the franchise yeah that's
like uh
that's like a show runner at hollywood
or something like that yeah
i think like half of those things
sounded like stuff that biff would do
like
consistency and knowing like all the
different threads but
the other the other stuff about like
managing style guides and
casting notes that's yeah yeah yeah life
is the guy explaining it to you
biff is the guy giving you the extended
cliff notes to give you
without the full reading like giving you
more detail understanding the story
he's not the one writing it yeah right
back in yeah
i didn't see that uh evan f applied for
it
i literally tagged him in the tweet i
was like you could go for it because
he's like he's good at retrospective i
guess he'd be good to kind of put
putting some of that stuff together
but as we when we had him on the show
his was just as much retrospective of
gameplay
mylon would have been another one i'm
sure another one yeah so it's like i'll
be curious to see who's got like
the combination of skill sets who ends
up coming to that one it could be
somebody we don't even know but you know
about you know i think it probably will
be
probably someone we don't know yet it'll
probably be somebody who's like been a
showrunner for like a a brand
before or like you know managed managed
uh some sort of like
interesting i wonder what the reporting
because like uh
structurally like who they report to
because didn't we remember when uh
luke and mark knows where didn't they
get elevated to kind of like
destiny i've got the exact title they're
like destiny executives at this point
they're above game director
yeah like they're above now but it also
was if i remember e something like the
context of like
where the story is going for like full
ownership
of the narrative yeah basically the ip
almost there above yeah
they only they're like the managers of
the ip for
possible tv shows and movies and other
crap that we wonder that's going to
happen about
but the game directors themselves that
was like justin truman and a couple
other people that like
seem to have taken their place
underneath that
that oh god
all right guys you convinced me i'll
apply i'm just going to make the
warlocks the most advanced class and
have osiris start a giant civil guardian
war
as intended i mean i don't see anything
wrong with that
it could happen anyway i don't even know
if you'll have to kick that one off
we'll get to that oh
they have my support yes yes there was
one other thing before we actually get
to the events of the week
um dmg community managers i will say
have not an easy job so i will
definitely give them all the props on
that one do they handle everything
perfect no but they tend to do a pretty
good job over at bungie
and i will say this week was a perfect
way that one was handled because
it all came down to the way somebody got
banned and basically his reaction to it
and i don't know if some of you guys
know how it went down i'm literally
looking for the tweet right now
somebody tweeted out and said hey i got
banned what the hell's kind of going on
was the gist of it and i'm trying to
find it real quick
and he replied back saying hey you know
let us look into it see what's going on
and then finally when he got back to him
here it is just got banned in d2 for the
second time
not a good sign with no explanation this
is kind of ridiculous i'd like some
people to
bungee to look into this there's no way
i get banned when i see mad shooters
play for months
tags cosmo and dmg dmg tag
replies bands are not issued with heart
reason the team has validated this
action multiple times thanks to
anti-cheat detection and investigation
for additional information i recommend
reading our account restrictions and
banning policies
he replied i'd like to see proof of what
i was doing that resulted in this ban
because as of right now this is
bs and then dmg replied follow up
took some time to triple check with the
security team we have detected two
accounts under your ownership using
cheat suites while playing destiny 2 and
have banned four accounts total
including bannovation this is our final
communication on this matter
period damn
i was like but that's like the most
professional way to smack somebody
upside the head it was kind of beautiful
so
i wanted to shout that out audacity to
go
dmg knowing he got a rap sheet
knowing he's loose in these cheating
streets
he got the nerve to be like this is bs
and i need proof of what
wow see what i heard some people talking
about think he may have had
alternate accounts but they know mac ips
they know ip addresses all that stuff so
they know the same
well these are linked like you may have
and he's a content creator with like 100
000 subs or something like that he's not
a small guy
and now band oh yeah he's a content
creator
he is um yeah he's no longer it was
before too
yeah so i was like i don't know all the
details he literally took all the links
off his twitter
so yep he's i will be curious if
anything comes out of that but they just
they have their research in their
security so they found something
they called me he got the rap sheet he
out hit that i mean
that's how they do it evontas con man
people forget the khan stands for
confidence you have the confidence to be
like
i'm not doing anything wrong the same
thing happened you guys remember that
the guy who caught plagiarizing at ign
yes yeah
after after he got caught he posted like
read all my reviews
by the way yeah that's what they do they
they hope they they think
they can it can't occur to them that
they'll ever get caught if they're just
yeah that's what it is
you're right yeah absolutely it's the
confidence it's the
they've been so used to getting away
with it but it's just so
brazen travis like like how like
it's one thing to complain and you're
going to custom
support support on the side but you're
publicly going to twitter
and dmg and dylan publicly like yo and
prove to be
that's next level though dmg
gave him a chance to save face but he
just kept coming
yeah so they pointed they pulled out the
record they pulled out the offenses the
misdemeanors the felonies
you're on them good on them for finally
uh yeah that tweet
i will read oh
back into a small country by the raid
boss dmg calif community manager
he thought he was too big you guys said
we don't even get a chance
that's already there um all right nice
nice appreciate it so yeah i just wanted
to call those couple things out because
every so often like something like a
destiny historian
like no other game is going to have that
and just the fact that this ip and
franchise has even
gotten to a point where we actually need
one of those is kind of interesting
but then on the other side to see some
unintelligent person try and come at
them like this and like
they've got all the we know destiny and
bungie has their data so of course
they're gonna know if you messed up and
they called him straight on it so i just
thought that was pretty good
um but that kind of covers a little bit
historic now we come to tuesday
who has played the story beats of the
week and who wants to go first i might
have to give it to prince
sir tai um how did it go when you logged
in on tuesday what did you get to
experience what are your thoughts
it's been an interesting week right so
tuesday i logged in
wondering all right this is actually
gonna be it are we actually gonna face
corey
and we did after um after you do the
override
and the first expunge like we got her
we're gonna go get her
so uh jump into the expunge after that
to face correa i thought it was um
one i did it solo i thought that would
be an adequate challenge for it
um with the light level the way to do it
and two the dialogue leading up to it
the dialogue at the final fight was
was very interesting osiris was making
me looking over my shoulder i was like
like dude can you chill am i gonna make
it through this expunge
and then at the end when you have um
mythrax
i chora and saint 14 in your ear
like cheering you on uh that couch
gaming like oh you got this you got this
and i was just like yo osiris you're
gonna
you're gonna believe in me too um
but the only thing you had to say was oh
you actually did it
you killed korea oh oh
oh so don't running that mission uh
i really liked the back and forth and
the mechanics that were introduced to
have you bring down
corey's shield once he got to the um
damaged phage phases of invincibility
uh i thought that with it being solo
i know some people complained it wasn't
hard enough that they felt korea should
have been like
a dungeon or a strike and which i can
see that i can also see it was an okay
enough challenge
doing it solo i was um in the mindset
enough
uh to where i felt like um there was at
least a little bit of payoff like i felt
like i did something
when korea um was killed
and the the wrap up afterward
with uh coming to talking and the toast
the good jobs
the lower tab opening up that the
endless night starting to dissipate a
little bit
people are happier there's gonna be a
celebration
and all except for pretty much lakshmi
was like job well done guardian see you
see you next time
um but lakshmi was like congratulations
no hard feelings
but this isn't over and i was just like
okay okay laxmi so laxmi
is not letting anything go the device
of her future vision she sees a storm
that is still
coming this is just the calm she said
for the storm
and then when we got the uh
the the trailer or that um solstice is
coming i was like oh
well i get i guess we'll wait for that i
guess that'll be hopefully
a big payoff in the epilogue at the end
of the season um but overall
i enjoyed this week's story beat for the
most part i felt like
it was a good uh culmination
for the endless knight um
essentially getting to enjoy a little
bit in a victory have a respite
of everyone being able to come together
finally
i noticed that saint and mythrax they
were getting along well they were joking
now
um which is a contrast from the tensions
that they had a couple weeks ago
i've enjoyed that as well no doubt
travis what about you how you been this
week
yeah man i i that osiris
sucks man he's so there's that moment
uh i think it's dirty which would
explode
which one i i underestimated you i will
not do that again
[Music]
you're like dude at this point this
isn't even osiris talking to us
right it's so obviously sabbath
crazy i think somebody else is posting i
don't know if this is a new thing or
maybe just something we notice now
because everybody's paranoid but
cyrus has like black veins on his head
have you guys seen that
he's got that somebody posted the
screenshot of that but he's got like
it looks like he's like corrupted
but yeah dude there's there's
something's coming there's gonna be
uh i i i still hate laxmi she kind of
like left with her tail between her legs
but i i hate her uh wanted to go away
but
yeah dude it was a good weekend in
destiny i i really like the uh
the model they're doing where they they
bring stuff out slowly do i like doing
expunge
every week no do i like doing the uh the
override event as often as i've had to
do it
absolutely not there's that challenge
where i have to do 20 corrupted chests
no thank you you know other than that
uh it's i think the story is stronger
than it's ever been week to week
like what we're getting and what they're
setting up and how it feels like stuff
is actually happening and
um it's awesome it's also just great to
be able to log on to destiny and play a
little bit
but not have to make it your entire life
uh which which we were forced to do when
they
you know only did one expansion per year
just like all right clear out a month
and a half two months because
destiny is the only thing you're gonna
get to do and now it feels like it's
more manageable i can play other games
and then log on to destiny every week
during reset and do all the stuff and
then after that i can just go back to
crucible if i
uh my home my warm and fuzzy crucible
and then uh
and then play other games when i when
you need to so it's good man
i'm pretty happy with the state of
destiny also that stasis nerf
i know you guys have probably talked
about it on the show but i have not
really gotten to talk
about it since uh since it happened uh
let's change the game man i mean you
don't really see uh stasis in
in crucible anymore so um it's
interesting
at least on console i don't know if
that's true on pc it's definitely much
lighter for sure
what about you sir oh suspicious
i gotta know how you feeling man how's
this week so
dude are you ready to say goodbye to
your uh warlock
yeah i think i don't know what's going
on but it's it's good man
i i really do get excited on tuesdays
you know they really do just because of
the law is so good and like what's gonna
happen this week right so you
you jump in and yeah you do your expunge
and you know okay cool
i mean you do it um override and then
you know okay cool you go to expunge and
yeah like
travis nailed it like i'm descending
down this
sponge and i'm hearing osiris talk and
he's just like
yeah you you did all these great things
and you know i often
underestimate you guardian i never will
again and i'm just like
whoa bro i'm more like this is really
chilling then you couple that
you know it was a little like tension
because you listen to that and then you
you're seeing the text
of whoever the hell that is saboteur and
quarry i already see your grave
you're getting all this like negative
energy future telling energy while
you're doing this
and then you know i did the initial one
and it was like okay boom
one more and i believe it was like
sponge delphi whatever it is
yeah so i'm like okay um now i see shout
out to tassie i know
like he's not a fan of the choreo fight
like he he's really not a fan of
it but i'm with i'm with prince like if
you do it
solo i'm i'm usually not a solo gamer be
honest i always play destiny in a
cooperative mode but
there is a challenge and a fun
um you know sense of accomplishment when
you do it solo and to me that's the way
it should be that mission should be
played i almost feel they should force
it as a solo activity
you know what i'm saying because it
really transforms and i i liked it i
like
bouncing around it was basically they
melded every expunged mechanic
into this last one but the thing i liked
about you had the two bosses
and then i actually liked when
corey starts to get low shout out to
deathbringer death bringing with the um
with the with the what i'm sure that
just nuked her oh
i just sit in the back shoot that thing
up in the air and i got the catalyst so
it hits harder every time
that you know the the deathbringer
things drop so um
yeah like i was doing my thing on her
butt i have to admit like
when she gets towards the end like she
ramps up she's like
it's like yeah it's like she said like
you don't play pong like it's like pong
blocks tetris blocks being thrown at you
i'm like yo
all right like yeah she was heating up
yeah she heat up i'm like okay
i liked it so for me you know it didn't
like like prince said perfectly
you know like satan had me hype come on
guardian
they said do it like everyone's couch
co-op cheering you on you do anything
i liked it so you get back you know you
have that moment and i wanted to see
what was going to go on obviously
you know um i thought what was
interesting
the endless night is not finished
yeah that honestly yeah you'll steal my
thunder a little bit there but
that's my one drawback to this whole
thing
is the fact that you you've literally
been like
hey whoever it is is controlling this
and it's like this
like it's forced delay to either
it's gotta last the week because now we
see the trailer for solstice we'll get
to later and looks fine
and i'm like why is it not as soon as
you kill aquaria it's done it's like oh
we need to untangle things i'm like
angle things
i was like unless that leads to
something six weeks from now which
once you saw the salsa trailer we
figured out it really doesn't i was just
like
dude as soon as you go back just be in a
new instance at the tower that's bright
that was the one thing i think that i
like like i enjoyed the fight you can go
back but
i agree that's been the one for me that
was like
man close cool anyway so you can keep
going keep going
yeah that was my my thought process but
also
like my new thing is i record i
screenshot every time
i quora is like yeah now we're going to
give all the data to osiris
and i'm like girl what are you going to
stop giving
this man is clearly the problem
you go this thing is not solved you know
let's get all our secret top secret
books and give that to her and all the
data and i'm like
so it's just like to me that's the part
it's like they keep
feeding you know osiris
all this information all this top secret
stuff
to pre to to to give savvy through this
strength so i think
we're really setting up for something
awful because that like you said he
they said unless that ain't over you
know what i'm saying it's still still
going on
they've stopped quarrier and i think
it's more of a
sabbath the vibe i get is sabathun is
testing right
and was definitely underestimated that
we'd be able to stop the first snare or
trap with this thing
but now i think it's gonna weave even
deeper into locking us into some type of
really bad situation
and i just want to know the thing that
is i'm dying to know e
is what will be the breakthrough moment
as guardians whether it be the guardian
or whether it be another npc
who finally you know reveals or lifts
the veil that we're being
duped here like i want to know what's
the moment whether it's like oh
you know several tunes walking through
the torah and you know just the mascara
rolls off
you know something has to happen you
know where someone goes wait a minute
and they pull aikora to the side or
someone has to get pulled to the side
and be like fam this is not it
and that's what i would not want to know
how they pay this off
so that the guardian now knows we're all
being duped
we're under savathun's whole spell or
whatever's gonna happen
and i'm curious about epilogue i do
think one more moment
should happen you know i think it looks
like we're going to take a break now
which chat is me
because i i do look forward to every
week i think it was nem put a tweet out
he was like this is the part of the
season i get sad because there's not
going to be
any more like when you beat it and you
see that triumph says yeah you completed
all for the most part all the story
beats of the season
you know what i'm saying like that
possibly you want to know you want this
thing to keep on and keep on
so um yeah i'm very curious but i'm
gonna give it to you like what's your
whole thought process with it and
when you were doing it and quarry a
fight and like
where are you at with this whole thing
this week uh i mean for me honestly just
with chat and a little bit of rumors and
some people looking around at
information
there's a lot of people who thought
there was going to be one more week as
well or doing this later on or maybe the
finale was going to be during epilogue
so when it finished expunged tartarus
and i was like now go do delphi i was
like oh this is a lot faster than i
thought
yeah so i was surprised to see that we
were going straight in uh the way that
kind of
season do we have by the way six
because he got four solstice and the two
for epilogue i believe
that's a lot that's a lot uh
this is gonna be small compared to the
next one but we'll get to that um
yeah so it's like when i jumped in i was
like oh i'm like when you start delphi
and you're like
you go through the opening you're like
cool i do my minute 15 second run bam
i'm in the middle of leviathan i was
like all right do this whole section
jump through you go bam bam oh here's
the portal and then i'm jumping into
sticks i'm like
okay i'm going over here i'm gonna do
the left side and then you jump in i'm
like portals back
jump i'm like all right now i'm on the
side that i never go on for
tartarus okay check and i'm like okay
now i think we're going in doing all
this on stream we jump in and just
slowly fall down i was like ah we
finally made it to the new section
but i like the way you got like the t's
like if you can do it it's like a minute
minute minute like you can go through
them pretty fast
but yeah it's like i went into it solo
as i usually do just because i like to
record this stuff as well
and as you jump in at first i'm like oh
this quarry and then it's like
taken shield going over hydroshield i'm
like there's not a lot of windows to put
the damage in there so i'm like sitting
here with a grenade launcher with
breaching clear i'm like
bank and then rocket launcher wait for
it wait towards fire so i'm like
trying to thread the needle between and
everything um nice
uh so i was like that was kind of cool
and then you're like damage phase i'm
like
taking guy over there regular guy over
there all right i'm gonna go kill the
taking guy first so
go over there and then you gotta pick up
the block and then you're like running
around then
yeah there's a couple great outtakes at
the end of my video because i'm like i
got this
crap it was like disappeared a couple
times
it was just it was a cool culmination
for
like the six weeks that we've been doing
this thing because they put a lot of
pieces together because you had to hold
the block then you had the floating
things then you had the
cannons then you had to kill the boss
now man i stepped like once you ran the
blocker on the outside of each boss
i'm just sitting back there going i'm
just like bombing from far away
and then i had tracking rock and so it's
just like breaching clear tagged fire
and i had to hit him twice
so like he was dead pretty quick jump
back to the middle then i was like
all right now he's only got one shield
and i was like okay now i'm kind of
understanding how this is to go
and did the other side and then finally
the first time i killed it so quick i
didn't even see the red walls flat me
i didn't even know i just like unloaded
my cool no shield bam bam dead
so sweet and then i went back for my
solo flawless video
and i literally traded in the air a red
wall coming at me
rocket going this way on a solo flawless
run we died together and that run
is one that didn't count so i did get to
experience the red walls and i was like
i was like no so
i opened the chest and it was like it's
like we're running back so i had to go
again
and then i was like kind of run through
shoot a rocket then dive off to the side
then run through shoot a rocket and dive
off to the other side
and it was like you could see because
it's just throwing like waves at you and
i'm just sitting off the
side of like underneath them i ended up
trying to stay out of the way and i was
like
okay so i gotta basically shoot and run
so
figured that out finally but it was
actually cool to see like when they're
you're like okay no shield this
shouldn't be that big of a deal and
after the first try
i had no idea it was coming so it's like
cool i just get to unload and i just
kind of stood there and i was like so
this is what you want to
holy like so i didn't see it coming yeah
so it's like i was not prepared
um but yeah it was just i thought the
culmination was cool and then you get
back to the tower and it's still dark
and i was pissed
so it's like for me that's like it was
such a buildup to be like
we're not done i'm like yeah such a
close moment because like you go back
you talk to him you do all the story
like you guys have covered all those
beats for me and it was just the fact
that the night was still there
and i was like if this isn't part of the
epilogue thing
and then you get to see they're like
unwinding it and i'm like okay fine this
is gonna be epilogue it's gonna be night
for a while we'll finally get to
some culminating event that happens and
then i see the solstice trailer the next
day which we'll get to a bit later
and i was like oh it looks bright and
i'm like that's next week so why don't
you do it now so that was my only
takeaway i was like you were really
you were really i just didn't like that
should have been the payoff for me
to go through and finally i mean the
endless night
to me yes the tower is a public area so
if they do it for you they'd have to do
it for the entire
uh game so then my question is of the
two philosophies doing it right away and
then having the people who haven't done
the mission yet
log in and possibly get spoiled that
this is the week or
just wait until tuesday and then do it
then and kind of let everybody have a
chance to catch up like which
which of those do you prefer because it
sounds like your
your issue is that you want it you want
it to be like when the last word was
finally beaten as a raid and like
everyone
got to know when it ended at the same
time you think it should be like that
for more events where it's like
real time uh i mean honestly it's like
yeah it's like when the last wish was
beaten
um that was cool to see the world thing
but i mean they do instancing all the
time
so it's like for me if i log into the
tower i should see a daylight tower and
if somebody hasn't beated yet
they still see a night tower and they
could probably do that just as what
you're looking at is almost a sky box
that wouldn't be hard to pick between
them so that was just that's for me is
like
if i've gone through and beaten it i
don't know that was just my little thing
it was like that just felt like a missed
moment i guess to like
have the light come back after we've
killed quaria for the seasonal event
and and i guess it was i was like okay
maybe i was kind of on board until i saw
the celsius trailer and if it's just i
have to wait a week it feels kind of
empty then if it was part of epilogue
and
some sabothune reveal and be like oh
here's the endless night but sabathune's
like
you know sitting behind osiris face or
something
like that being like sweet cool that's
amazing way to hold on to it but if it's
just like
we have to get through the week it felt
like it could have been now that was i
guess more than anything for me
a possible alternative they could have
done because like travis said it really
would have been like an instance issue
or a solo player to experience then this
night dissipating
they could have possibly used the elixir
camp for that
they could you could have loaded back in
with your
anna french congratulating you as the
endless knight is lifting because that's
also a space that we see
outside where the night is very clear
and stark there so they had it
dissipating into daylight there
right it could have been giving that
kind of immersion a little player feel
that's who you're going yeah i mean it's
funny he was very angry about that
i was surprised i didn't i don't know i
i just
felt like to me i actually liked it
because part of me was like
they you know was the pump fake they
build you up like you know the whole
season is about this and you got to do
this and this is going to end it which
of course
you're an amazing splicer now wear this
and then
quarry or you know so they to me they
built it up and i was like
yeah it ain't over like i i was because
to me
sabathun is still the mastermind and
still
have stuff going on so it i had the
opposite effect like it would have been
anti-climatic to me if it was like all
right yeah we did it
back to normal guys like that's just me
but i understand where he's coming from
it's just interesting to see his take on
it on
on that one we've just yeah it's like i
mean we've had the bait and switch for a
while every so often it's nice to get a
little story payoff so it's like another
dangling thread i'm like finish this
that's all we've
been doing a lot of those we've had a
lot of those i want to i want to finish
up because like somebody in chat even
asked like dakota asked like where is
zevo wrath and all this i'm like
i don't know we haven't heard anything
since season of the hunt and sabbath
still setting us up i'm like there's
another sister she may not be
the big sister but piss off little
sisters she still may be somebody to
worry about and we haven't heard
anything so again there's
there's enough open stuff i'm like we
had a chance for a smidge of closure and
i think i was like that's just me so
i'm sure it was fine either way again
destiny continues to be
awful at actually closing any of its
story threads it
it's constantly opening new ones that
weren't really a part of like the main
canon and then not closing it it's like
it's like a guy who's like dating a
bunch of girls but he doesn't want to
commit to any because he feels like
it'll close up his options you know
he's like oh i don't want to pick a
direction because i might need to pivot
and go over here and try new things so
they're just
they just seem like completely incapable
of just picking a direction and just
like following it to the end
it's just every every season it's a new
uh thread that we now have to
keep track of and remember i forgot
about zebra wrath already like that
exactly the problem that's a whole
reason behind the season and we forgot
about it that's that doesn't
i mean seasonal hunt had some issues
anyway but i was like that's an entire
piece of something
and you guys honestly haven't forgot
about and i didn't think about it until
dakota said it at that moment i'm like
yeah so that's one of those weird
there's a lot of weight that keeps being
pushed on witch queen at this point and
i don't know if it can
ever live up the more it keeps being put
on it yeah so it's not going to pull
together all 18 of the
loose threads and make them you know one
comprehensible story
there's just no way it's going to do the
campaign that lasted 30 missions and
answered
all your questions yeah no way and even
if you have three years to do it i i
doubt that they can do it so
right we avenged the dreaming city but
the curse is still there
yeah exactly that one still blows my
mind
some people are wondering at least my
chat's always like couple of the guys in
there i know new red and black wings
always go back and forth
if if the dreaming city was next season
with the battery as like
a catalyst to like do enough to
really push witch queen to us because
the dreaming city and the death battery
for her if we finally do anything to
resolve put any issue into that with the
whole dreaming city loop and everything
if we finally have an issue with that
next season
to go into witchcraft that's like could
be a thing that actually ties it
together to be like oh
my battery's stopped and my worms piss
now i gotta go figure out why i like
a lot of speculation and that's a very
poor description of lore but
would be cool to see again like the
story next season's gonna be
interesting for what takes us into
what's supposed to be huge
so i agree but yeah i would say we
definitely all
enjoyed it a lot but definitely it's
good to see everybody had slightly
different takes on it too
because when it comes to stuff like this
everybody's getting a different piece
um so i did hate the final boss fight
though i'm with paul now
really the thing that irritates me about
these
big like finales is that how much work
again i i'm gonna sound like in like a
like a douchey
a douche
sir how hard could it be to create a
model for a new type of enemy
he's just a hydra he's just a guard
you're a man
he has his little bat wings
he had the force field he had the cool
force field he was they gave him two
shields
minor variations yeah it's like every
every enemy i fight is one it's like oh
it's
like that just because we've heard so
much about uh korea and i was just
thinking like oh this
this has got to be like so like finally
there's going to be something weird that
we fight and uh
it's just yeah i just i can't i can't
find a hydra and be like oh
at first the spawn animation it made me
think like yeah
it's going to be new because it kind of
unfolded down there oh come on they just
did a hydra again
they like fake me out it's like when
golgoroth spawns in the king's fall and
you see the little tendrils and they're
like oh
it's gonna be crazy and then it's just
an ogre you're like ah
what the hell you know i like the whole
thing is the enemy type right like like
for example like what curse would we
actually
even though curse of science was bad i
mean yeah i felt the panoptis model yeah
like model that would have been at least
fresher i think than just a hydra but
i just i mean again armchair developer
i'm sure it's harder than it is no no no
i'm with you i i take it back i take it
i'm waiting because you're not asking
something i feel crazy you're just
asking for a new model type for a boss
right that
that i don't feel that is i mean
obviously it's not easy but i'm just
saying like
i don't feel that's too ridiculously
like
unreasonable to ask for for
a a character in the lord has been built
up so
long that yeah it kind of deserves a
unique payoff
how would you guys feel if we fight
sabbath and it's just like a
witch looking like i'm the goal i'm
gonna be mad like i
would better not be the omnigo model
yeah
even not dolan karu but no it's like
that's where he gets into the whole
interesting debate of
this is a season this is one mission
that people are probably going to play
maybe one time how much resources do we
put into this
or can we use it is a taken hydra really
kind of the first time that's been
majorly a thing
do we kind of meld those two together
give it two shields maybe they'll like
give it some mechanics oh
it's cool i'm not i get but how many
people before now knew who courier was
what was it corey of my transformer okay
we're on a destiny podcast
outside of this the general public who's
like i'm gonna do my strikes this week
who's mario what am i fighting cool this
was fun
like i mean here's my question e here's
my question
do we really think at this point there
are any casual destiny players left
are there people playing destiny who are
like oh yeah you know i don't really
know much about the story i just log in
and play it like i feel like there
are at the main campaigns but during
these seasons
i feel like it's it's dead except for
the people who are on the reddit
i was like one of my last words one of
my most popular videos
every season is the leveling guide which
tells me there's enough people who
haven't played in a long enough time
it's like there's enough people that
haven't played a long enough time that
like hey this really helped me out and
i'm like that was like two days ago what
are you looking at this for
like eight weeks in they're jumping in
and i'm like
okay yeah and believe me i'm floored too
but that's why one of those it's like a
evergreen video for me because it's like
they always have
life and i'm surprised but they do
because
yeah it just checks in and same thing
like as soon as
like i said uh when they put destiny in
game pass right
and i'm seeing people they're like two
weeks behind and they're like yo how did
you do
that and i'm like y'all still okay like
it blows my mind
that it's so casualized so it's like we
really are the minority yeah as much as
hardcore we are we are the
minority with this game there are people
who still hit me up i'll put something
up on twitter
where i like i'll make fun of the
storyline beat of the week
and people are like yeah man i i just
got back in
you know two three weeks ago and i'm
like really like like
it's surprising to me it really is i
think that model the free to play
couple with game pass people are trying
it and they're still
behind and that cadence works for them i
forgot about game
i guess i'm living in a bubble but
everyone i play with like
all the casuals they play the main
expansions and then
after a month they're gone and they
don't go back until the next year at the
next expansion but they're not playing
like the seasons and so yeah if you
catch like
seasons or like well yeah like did you
listen to
this destiny podcast on this one and i'm
just like you guys are nerds like i
don't know
nerds nerds yeah no i was just like
that's kind of one of those is
where people can choose i mean steam
sales and other things we just find like
forsaken shadow keep and stuff's like on
sale and they jump back in and they're
like
where is it now and that's when they
pick up this current season for like 10
bucks and jump in
randomly eight weeks late now the cool
thing about the seasonal model now
they can go experience a couple of the
other seasons they can catch up on the
story of the season so they'll see that
stuff but
i'm always surprised how frequently i
have a channel because they're people
who don't know what that was going on
basically like that's literally why i'm
here
one of the reasons is to help people
with stuff
that i take for granted and honestly
it's like i've joked about asking my
wife to play destiny
she would probably never want to do it
she'd probably hate me for it but if she
ever did it would be more the
realization of stuff that we all take
for granted
if you listen to the podcast if you
already aware if you're doing master
level difficulties if you run the raid
on a weekly basis
that stuff is so second nature to you
it's not even funny but the average
person is like
what does this currency do how does this
like there's so many so many systems in
this game
if you haven't even played in two years
you're like i don't even understand
what's happening
oh my god i'm having so many neurons
fire in my brain right now of why you
bring up world of warcraft all the time
on this podcast
it's because you have a vested interest
in
bungie making destiny more convoluted
because then
you're in the pocket of big complex
that's your
that's your uh your business model oh my
god playing the long game
it all makes sense now
i've been exposed i've been exposed
i just cracked the domino of ivantos in
southend's great plan on that
bombshell no it's not really uh but i
did want to say
yeah so very cool week so far in the
story seems like we definitely seem to
be moving in a cool direction
uh dab for y'all um
but i definitely want to say we also got
news on wednesday
of a i was about to say new activity
coming back
we have an activity coming into the game
again
whoever wants to take it first on
solstice of heroes thoughts on our
approaching
summer event spiciest take goes first
what would you do if i just projectile
vomited
as soon as you came to the floor i was
like if you're on video just
if i could projectile vomit on command
that would have been the moment i choose
to do it
like let's get out
okay yeah i probably have the spiciest
taste yeah go for it because i know you
guys
i am sick and tired of this event that
seems to exist
purely to sell me eververse items like
ea eaz was cool the first time but they
just keep
rehashing it and honestly this is a
complaint of mine for a lot of their
live events as they're just
so rehashed and i remember there used to
be some mystery to it back in the day
when they'd redo these events you'd be
like oh i wonder how they're going to
modify this one
this time i feel like every time they do
it i know exactly what's going to happen
like it's before i even log on i know
what's expected of me solstice of heroes
like will i do it yes
will i hate myself for doing it
absolutely but
but like you know it just i i feel like
they're kind of spinning their wheels
with these seasonal events it makes me
wonder if we even really need them
i'm excited for the new shotgun that's
all i have to say i mean i'm just not
cool even though that's a real skin as
well
it is a reskin yeah exactly i i will do
this
but you're gonna hate yourself while you
do it
projectile obama guardians out yeah
projectile vomit is my new guardians out
that's just how i'm gonna end
the show anytime
uh yeah so yeah i'm not excited about
this event but uh
but you know whatever i'll play it uh
prince tai uh yeah i was
i was definitely interested with the
perspective of people who have done this
a lot more than i have this is going to
be my second time
going to the eaz and uh
i need a little animated blueberry to
put in your corner now
ah are you gonna blue bury me
hearing the so like i heard the
complaints of
before like last year when it rolled
back around everyone started rolling
their eyes here with the eaz
infinite forest all these live seasonal
events
and easy was pretty cool uh watching the
trailer for it this year
again um it being my second time i'll
probably
you know run it enough just to get me
through to my magnificent set of my
armor
and maybe get a couple different roles
for the shotgun it does look nice
and i'll probably be done with it i
didn't really play a lot of eaz last
year as well it
it isn't an activity that is enjoyable
even to a new player at the time of
grinding over and over
the armor sets this year i've heard that
is similar to
armor said two years ago in aesthetic
but i personally
liked last year's better actually for
how
it looks for the warlock the glowst
still look really nice um
and yeah again like people have already
mentioned for the most part
it's going to be marketing a lot of new
cosmetics coming to the river store
i will say the most interesting thing is
that baby shark ghost show
that has me hyped out of everything so
i'm definitely they got me for that one
i'm gonna cop that one
um but yeah it was it was like when i
saw the trailer
and they did their job right there you
bought a ghost shell they're done
that's all they needed to do if they
sold in one go i don't care if you log
in for the other four weeks
you just guaranteed soul sister heroes
for another three years
um yeah when i watched the trailer it
was cool seeing myth wrecks narrating
you know
this is our victory guardian let's
celebrate
but i wasn't that excited honestly when
the
trailer came out i was kind of deflated
a little bit like ah
i'm really gonna wait huh i gotta wait
till the epilogue to know how this is
gonna shake out
um but it'll be a nice nice little break
enjoy some eaz do something different
um yeah cog
so far glowing recommendations from the
first suit can i take it over to my
clothes
so defeated i love it it's just
hilarious
i mean it's it sounds this it's
it's what's delta sources does this is
what they do you know i mean
you know i'll jump in for a minute i
don't even think i'm that excited
about the seasonal i mean the solstice
weapon
but after reading the um the sandbox
which i'm really excited for we'll get
into
i think i know why it is that because i
appear that
this appears to be a rapid fire shotgun
correct right
you know uh yeah rapid fire energy i
think it's solar
right which i feel the new meta will be
shifting to
what's when what happened to uh a lot of
people's uh shotgun
the apes are gonna be bad the shockings
are not gonna be happy yeah travis
but um yeah i think that's it you know
i'm with travis it's like
i actually liked eaz when it first came
out i i did i thought it was a nice
unique thing
it was cool but it's like yeah it's like
we're getting so much of a recycling
of the same event with really not too
much of a variant
and it just again i hate to use that
word again it just it screams to me
resources it screams to me
rehashed it screams to me placeholder
stretch
things out to get to the finish line and
i think that that's where we all with
this i i mean i'm not
i don't know how much i will commit this
one i'm gonna be honest like i'm not
too sure how i'm gonna commit to this
because none of this
like i was trying to look at something
okay what's gonna get me
to connect and i'm with uh what's called
prince like
the suit is okay as a warlock it's
okay you know you know what had me hype
e that's what i knew i wasn't i was
disinterested
i was like well i might want the shirt i
was like i forgot to mention i might get
the jersey
i like the shirt a little bit and me i
got every destiny swag know the man
bungie has cashed out
salute rc i see you like bungie has
cashed out on me they have pit me i am a
fashion model for bungie basically on
every event
with what they do because i have to get
sort of sure i'm like i might want that
because
it's more of a of a show-off thing like
yo you did
it you know there's proof of
accomplishment but
other than that ghosts ain't doing it
for me
got a destiny time that's beautiful
right there that's how you do it
the glows ain't doing it for me i mean
the spot the sparrow the sparrow look
cool
it's probably cool you know but it ain't
nothing so crazy that we haven't seen
from like the dawning or something so
it's like
i don't know he i might like sit in my
house you might skip off i don't know
man like i'm not getting the vibe
like i need to be in it maybe i don't
know maybe there's some god rolls
maybe some new perks on that gun maybe
somebody finds out about that shotgun
because i know it's going to be meta
that i know because when that shotgun
metal we get into it
it's going to it's ramping fire yeah
yeah rapid fire is gonna be the thing
but other than that i don't know
man where are you at
i'm gonna probably make a video to take
the rare to the legendary and the what
is it
i can't even remember that whatever
magnificence the last one so
two videos one each day for that and
again if i can get the shirt and i'm out
i'm done
like it's short and sweet for me i don't
i'm not gonna do three characters i
definitely do not care enough to do that
even if they did give you a currency
this time instead of just
making the other characters go faster
you have to play 30 gambit matches you
oh i haven't touched gambit this season
for a very specific reason last season
they screwed me over on the seasonal
challenges like
two-thirds through that list they're
like oh now you gotta get the full ranks
and i'm like i've already been going
through kills and everything else can
you tell me that's not retroactive i've
covered this and i'm like
so i did not touch it so this season
zero gambit so far so if i am gonna go
work on challenges which i still can't
decide if i care enough to probably not
that's just the thing it's like we're at
the point where seasonal models are
go do some bounties go do some strikes
go kill these things kill them in a
specific way use this weapon use this
weapon use ark use solar use void like
we've done this stuff for years and i
don't mean to like beat a dead horse
because we are definitely doing that
but it is to a point where i'm kind of
with you travis like
would you rather not have the event and
just have some down time
or and again this is the point where
it's like is this the marketing and this
is the eververse and this is how they
pay some bills
like there's design like you have a
number of designers they've already set
the stage they've got the ez they built
that years ago
now you have designers building armor
and weapons and cosmetics that can make
them some money
and it's their choice of like hey i mean
what did what did ty
say i'm gonna get that baby shark ghost
just cuz
that's literally all they care about if
they can do that one thing to each
person whether you buy one set of armor
for one class
be like oh you don't have enough bright
dust just you know spend five or six
bucks on silver or 15 or whatever god
awful amount it is like
if they get that at a one percent of
these they keep you know lining their
coffers with some money like that's it
so do i buy the t-shirt and again i'm
sure most of the prop most of it goes to
them and
some goes to charity but it's like yeah
i'll take the shirt sometimes but for me
it's
i've got a couple glows i still don't
use those because sometimes they're a
bit much
and overall they've had so many issues
with these they've got some
clarification on the previous
solstice armors or you know you might be
able to use them before
and you'll be able to you can't if you
don't have them previously you'll be
able to
maybe buy them in a future year but
right now you can so
i don't know it's because this leads me
to think season 15 will have about a
seven eight week story
then we're gonna get a season of the la
or festival of lust you're gonna have a
little break in thanksgiving then the
dawning
and they're going to be exactly the same
as it was but previously it's just you
know the same everest evil avonte
try and suck up your cash cosmetics so
it's it's hard to get excited as a as a
veteran player at this point
somebody who hasn't seen it before be
like oh this is kind of cool but it's
like
we do get some glowy armor we've had it
before we're going to the easy we're
doing the same bounties
it's probably going to be almost the
same checklist on the armor i can
imagine there's not going to be too much
different
so i am i'm not saying i'm not saying
they have to like
come up with a whole new event every
year i'm just saying like
surprise us in some way like remix it
they used to remix it and kind of make
it a little bit different and
iterate it rather than just rehashing
because it's like if you want to sell me
a whole bunch of eververse stuff
fine but like at least give me a reason
to log in and play the game right now
reason to log in and buy everything on
my everest check
checklist and then log off you know what
i mean like that's that
it's just the same thing no that's what
that's literally what i do because i get
suckered because i'm like oh what's the
new emotes
all right cool and then i'm like i'm
that dude don't roll your eyes travis
david
i mean i'm that dude they get me oh i
you know what's wrong i don't even
they're not even getting me i'm
willingly going in there for foolishness
i am
willingly because i think it's so cool
that they got whatever these little
animations or whatever and you know if i
see and then because i'm you know the
fashion lock i got to make sure
you know if there's you know something
that matches with an outfit or a new
ornament that looks cool
[ __ ] you're the reason they removed all
those tabs from the inventory so they
could add the eververse tab
onto the uh the main menu i'm that guy
someone
told all your sins i'm awful
i've been there oh okay this is the new
suit all right and i'm already thinking
about outfits to go with my stasis look
all right this is my other outfit to go
with with ark and
that's me so it's just like i know i'm
funding the damn game and the
foolishness but to your point travis
it's like
you just want a twist you just want
a curveball you want something to say
okay this is
not the exact same assembly line event
that you keep
regurgitating every year well we're
gonna have the same
bosses we're gonna see the same cycle of
enemies that come through there i mean
that stuff's not even going to change
which is really going to be they don't
it's like oh you got your cabal yep
you've got the two or three cabal
colossus then you got the witch that
splits from brood hold like
that's the thing too is that's gonna
probably be the same and that's the part
when you get in there you're like
now i've truly seen this exactly before
yeah so even for ty
it's like he's not likely going to see
hardly anything different
unless they surprised me but i really
really don't expect it it's just kind of
one of those
if you played it last year you're going
to know what's coming yeah and
and um ibantis brought up a good point
is for people who are definitely
exhausted of this what would you rather
have would you rather them just
not do it take a break until epilogue
time for next season
or again bring something for traditional
sake to have that event
and i think earlier when we mentioned
the casual audience
it's always going to be someone's first
solstice of heroes
so to them all this stuff is brand new
like for me last year
and it's a hard balancing act because
for me it'd just be my second one my
selfish answer would be yeah just take a
break
allow players to go play other games
then come back but not only
are they bringing it for someone to
experience for the first time
they have resources but also that
marketing engagement they want to try
and keep you playing for some reason
yeah that that's the dilemma that's what
i think what's going on here and
you know the hardcore have to make a
decision and i think we
all are doing it right for the most part
which is yo i'm in for a second i do one
thing that i like or anything that
catches my eye and then you go play
other games until
you see something that you know comes
back or whether it be you know for me
i guess the the more disappointing
factor
is kind of like when i saw solstice
and i'm like damn the narrative beat is
over so i'm like yeah
that that's what made me sad and again
them is the one who put the same
i think a similar tweet so i'm like now
i know i'm like really not gonna log it
as much and i was hoping it'd be
something that would catch it but
there is something else as we will get
on with that twelve
we talk about for me that i'm like okay
i'll log in for these these things you
know what i'm saying
but but if it was just up to the
solstice but if the 12 ended with
solstice this week
yeah i'd have been like i'm not long
they they did some stuff for me after
we're gonna get into
right i'm like okay all right i want to
know what's going on here
uh which pretty much takes us into the
next thing we'll go down the swab
into not what you're quite waiting for
but
we do have the world of your favorite
raid
and we got a fancy new difficulty in a
raid
it has been a minute since we've had a
difficulty in a raid so
beginning in all caps tuesday july 6 a
vault of glass
master difficulty will become available
to all players
do you guys want me to like spill out of
the info or stop on topics
okay thoughts anybody everybody hear you
yeah i'm fine with that
all right how you enter uh you'll be
signing in tuesday vault of glass will
be on master difficulty
you can go in doesn't matter your power
level so it's unlike a grand master
there's no minimum
enemies will be at 13 50 power
that's on the power level that's high
i got some leveling to do what what
level
i was like what what level are you guys
max right now i'm like 13
30. just got there yeah i'm about i'm
about
at 13 30. again when i read that line
i was like excited for master and then i
was like yeah i was like
because i'm not high enough yet and i've
been looking forward to master vlog it's
just
i haven't been able to just grind light
level to be ready for 1350.
and it's my own fault i've been
purposely not doing all the pinnacles
every week because i've been doing a
bare minimum you know maybe expunge is
the only one because i've been farming
roles
some of the cool weapons that i like
from um the spy stuff but what about you
travis uh
light level sir yeah
i'm 13 26. hey there we go that's not
too bad but yeah definitely not ready
13 26 in chat i'm 13 33 and i've been
playing more than i probably should have
been
wow and i'm still not ready for gs no
idea
so you're not obviously not supposed to
get to 13.50 so it's the idea that you
get to 1335 or so probably
13 35 or 1340 depending
like it's so i mean 1320 is the pinnacle
cap
so then it's how close you are if you
could at least probably be 1331
then you're within that 20 delta where
it's probably not brutal but i mean
every point closer is going to make a
difference so
it's really a question of how much time
do you have to be a bounty goblin which
is part of the problem
the grand master light level for enemies
is 1360.
1360 enemies and 1335 is the level
correct
right so it's 10 power level below grand
master
yep but it's the same it's like or is
the master nightfall this season 1350
is that or 1360 yeah i mean they if
it was 1360 for a raid it would be
impossible because
nightfall like the only reason people
beat those is because they use like
cheeses and exploits and strategies that
you wouldn't normally do but like
in rage you have to be in open combat
which right basically never do in grand
master nightfall so
i'm gonna be very also no power level
cap right it's not like grand master
where you have to be
they like artificially yeah there's no
contest cap it's you can be as high as
you want so that's why i was like
those people who have been lifelessly
grinding out bounties and whatever
they've been doing
they're gonna probably be able to have a
better option in here you know vault of
glass mods might do some things but
the level is it's a spicy level i will
be curious to watch on tuesday from afar
seeing the seeing everybody put bash
their head against it there's some
people i know who run raids very
smoothly
they may be totally fine i'll just by be
kind of curious to see
you'll have the elites that'll probably
be okay put them on so you can put the
loadouts together
yeah because they'll blow through it
because their light level will be super
high for your bounties right
right but you want to talk about a short
list of people that are going to do
this probably um
what's up are you going to do it
he's not on the list oh yeah i'm going
to do it
no i'm going to do it all right we're
going to run it there oh
as
maybe yeah go go big them just told me
i'm 13 31 with the right outfit
okay all right uh what you can earn
first up master vault of glass unlocks
the final triumphs required for fate
breaker seal so you'll
actually have to do this once completed
players may earn their in-game title and
purchase the pin
cool there is a picture this is the only
reason i may ever fathom it like the end
of a season
the ship yes i like that ship i will say
that is one of now it's probably similar
to a ship
we but the fact that the the spires on
the side of the ship are made of big ass
crystals i am
kind of that's one of the more unique
ships i've seen
you know how we get what is that unique
content based on in-game
stuff as opposed to being in everything
that i'm okay with
lost that ship out stevie
you know that's gonna be a random drop
like um
the wrath of the quest
well no what's the ship from uh wrath
wrath of the machine ship you know what
i'm talking about yeah if you take a
people yeah
there's a very like it's a very siva
looking ship
very few people have that one and that's
when you had to grab a random drop
so there's a random drop that's going to
be brutal
yeah in that same vein i would imagine
just
they already time gated everything else
we'll get to that here right now
second master vault of glass will also
introduce time loss weapons timeless
weapons can be comparable to adept
weaponry from grand master nightfalls or
flawless trials
but offer an additional perk in columns
three and four
just to clarify for anybody listening so
you have
four typical columns on a weapon
the first one is going to be something
like clips well not clips the first one
is going to be something like sights
or anything of that nature second one is
going to be reloads or
clips or magazines those are always
going to have your options but normally
the third and fourth column has a single
option
sometimes through the seasonal offerings
we'll have the fourth column
have two options time lost weapons have
the third
and the fourth column having two options
so your chances that
better rolls are definitely going to be
a lot higher yep but before we get
into that idea complete vault of glass
chal
um complete vault of glass challenges
in master difficulty of the activity and
you will be rewarded
each week will feature a specific time
loss weapon for you to hunt
rotating alongside the available
challenge once you've earned a timeless
weapon you may purchase an additional
roll
from the chest at the end of the raid on
master difficulty using spoils of
conquest god knows how pricey those are
going to be
note that they will be pricier uh please
note
weekly reward lockouts are shared
between both
normal and master difficulty of vault of
glass that means
encounters challenges and hidden chests
will only award gear the first time you
complete them in either
activity each week they must complete it
at b at master first to earn time lost
weapons
and stat focused armor lastly i hate
that
yeah i gotta stop there i hate that i've
never done that before
no they've ever done that i don't think
they've ever done that that's foul
that's fine yeah let us let us eat
come on let us eat don't don't be like
that
now you forcing us to jump and dead and
if you don't if you did it sometimes you
did the normal for the week
and then you decide to bump up the
challenge and you get nothing
right you're out of luck you have to do
master first
you can't like jump and be like oh i got
some friends on let me do a normal raid
nope you're going to stop people from
raiding
yeah if you can manage to do master you
can never do normal again
because like why would you ever even do
normal right
yep yeah this is weird i don't it's
awful
this is one of those times where i
wonder like they
really are forcing a stretch here
they're really spacing it out yeah
they're time gaining everything
can you imagine like hey what week is
what's the ones you're going to want
fatebringer
i'm going to be rip that's going to be
on like the gate
bringer is going to be on like the
gatekeeper challenge which is i was
rolling with fallout and we was like
working on the challenges and we had a
pretty good team
but we were like going through the
challenges pretty well not too bad
the gatekeeper challenge is the one that
we like had the hardest time with
on normal now granted we also cheesed
atheon so i'm not sure that one's going
to be easy either
it's like you have to i can't even
remember
oh you have to kill the shielded
minotaur that's walking down yeah you
have to kill it with the shield
so it's always this weird time gate of
like trying to go back and something
like that i think
i can't remember specifically what it
was something you had to kill with like
the shield only
or something specific or nose with your
super you had to kill
it with your super so you were like
trying to stack orbs for everybody and
that's what you're trying to you had to
kill with your super something weird
so that's why it was really strange and
then of course atheon you can't kill one
um what are the little exploding harpies
succulents right right you can't kill
one succulent
you gotta leave them up all whole time
supplicants supple thank you succulents
yeah
succulent yeah now we're in succubus and
we've gone off the deep end but yeah
supplicant thank you
um but yeah like that and you know
like they're gonna put the best stuff
back there i'm like you people are gonna
just bash their mind through and then
you get to the point like is that
just worth it so i wanted to see you
guys
so you guys obviously have opinions was
like so the weekly lockout yay
quick answers
hey oh yeah what would you guys do
different i'm curious
yeah yeah yeah like while everything you
just did
do the opposite of that
it almost feels like you're being
punished
for wanting to do harder content yes
yeah i was like that's it was
the fact that you can't go like you you
may have a group that could do master
later in the week
but you can't go run a raid period can
you mention any of the streams
hey anybody want to jump in you can't do
any helps any nothing
you can't go do a normal you can't go do
normal for practice
good point just to practice be like okay
we got this this might be harder
let's see how efficient we can make this
one and then you can't
uh you can't practice you just have to
go hard
or master it you just have to go
straight to it that's
it's a very very weird decision and
again yes first time for sure
i think this is a decision or a
limitation i think it's a forced
limitation
like a limitation on their tech i mean
or just
no i think that's a decision i think
that's their choice yeah
listen this content this season is light
and they to the fact that they're doing
this
specific time loss weapon of the week
like they basically try to trouse osiris
it
like you're going to be like like come
on man like that's the thing
and we know let's be honest like i would
be shocked
if fate bringer is early in the season
oh it will not be
i will be shocked if they do that
because we know
to get you to play to keep you invested
it's better for them to have that later
to keep on going and then you know i'm
saying have some life at the end of the
season because that's the one people are
going to be we're going to get a time
loss time loss pray that's revenge and
uninstall the game
be like nope about all that work for
that no
you can't even just beat master you have
to do the challenge you
have to do the challenge i have to do
the challenge like
so you have to do the hardest possible
thing
just to get a weapon with like double
drops it's not like it's better
it's not like it does any more damage
it's not like it's going to have a
higher stat
it's not going to have anything other
than a double perk and i think that's
the point where
options yeah but yeah it's like you get
more perks but i'm like
wouldn't it be better just to farm
normal and go buy like
um cash at the end yeah use your spoils
than trying to do that
for the average group i would imagine do
you guys
what do you guys think what you think
prince
uh yeah like what ubanta said i think
that
or this philosophy on limiting the
player in such a way for harder content
not even for a guarantee on something
really good or anything that's going to
break the game if you get it um not to
mention for those people who may still
be hunting
or say like vex from this dungeon and
they want to do the master difficulty
the drop rate doesn't change it's still
going to be whatever it is now
um even when doing the challenge on top
of the master and someone in the chat
even mentioned
this hits sherpa is really hard because
now what are you going to do
yeah this hit sharp is hard they didn't
think that part through
shout out to back for that he being evil
he said they're gonna put up for social
they can put matt you a master raid as a
requirement
to master where a piece of solstice all
right oh my god
yo could you imagine if they did that
that'll be on the
just don't throw that out in the
universe just to give them an idea
out there on the one hand like i get it
you're
um you're wanting players to engage in
this content and let it um stretch out
for a period of time and satisfy but on
the other hand
i don't think they should be as cautious
or afraid to like you said like
let the players enjoy let them eat let
them they're
willingly putting themselves through
such challenging content of not just the
master higher light level
but having to do the challenge on top of
it to earn
these timeless weapons that it's not
even a guarantee that they're great per
combination it's just you have
a greater chance
i agree i agree it's it to me it's
getting i
hate forced engagement bro i just i
cannot
end it it's like it's so and they're not
even being
subtle they're not even hiding it it's
just blatant
forced engagement to keep you coming
back each week and it's just like
i think the community sees right through
it uh travis
what
this is uh
he can't even muster the effort it's not
worth it
i'm putting as much effort into this
rant as bungie does into their content
um
[Laughter]
we love you guys but yeah yeah i know
bungie
love you you made you made a great game
i like that you're supporting it i just
wish that
i wish that there was
the destiny's biggest problem is that it
lacks content
that's always been its thing like it
people always put like
you know i've been on lots of shows and
they'll always ask me like oh so what
what could you change if you could
change one thing about destiny and to me
it's like
obviously the thing that everyone
actually wants to change about destiny
yeah there's like
problems with leveling there's problems
with loot and there's problems with
uh story and all this other stuff but
the actual problem of destiny is that
it would i don't think it it either
wasn't designed to be played every
single day
at least in its original conception or
it was designed to do that and they
underestimated by a lot
how much that work it's actually going
to take to do that and so
the biggest problem with destiny has
always been that they just don't have
enough content and it's not really a
solvable problem you can't just like
throw bodies at it and have like nine
studios thousands of people working on
destiny to make sure that
there's enough content where you'll play
every day and not get bored but
at a certain point the the amount of
the amount of stretching that they do
especially before a
large uh content release like this one
that they're
behind on because they did a delay i
don't even want to think about what it's
going to be like next
week oh my gosh
i have been out every week yeah dude
iron
it's frustrating because it's so blatant
right yes
everyone knows what the problem is and
rather than just being like
yo we don't have enough enough content
to keep going so take a break or
whatever they're just like
hey here's a reskinned weapon and an
event you've done nine times and a raid
that we just made artificially
more difficult and loot that takes
longer to get and
here's more stuff to buy at eververse
cog and just yeah
just you're right it's like it it makes
me
just at a certain point just be like all
right there's no way i'm going to beat
my head against the wall and keep doing
this i have other games that i have to
play
and like actually have to for work and
at a certain point i just start to
to get it makes me less likely to play
the game yeah or
or just retreat to crucible because
crucible is a loop that
they've decided a long time ago they
weren't even going to try putting
content
into so you know that was
it's years in the making of them not
even trying there so
i think i think pve folks are now
getting the treatment the crucible
players have gotten for years to be
honest like now you understand our pain
because
like this is lightly they got mad yeah
that's true
we haven't been way worse way worse over
here we struggling out here
yeah we're over here watching our own
developers out here with another girl
working on a different game you know
what i mean and like and we're just
sitting there like but what about us
have you forgotten
have you forgotten us your your high
school sweethearts we've been here for
you this whole time
uh so yeah i i i'm
endlessly frustrated by this to the
point where you know if you ask me to
just do a rant on it it's like i don't
even know what target to pick that's why
i was flabbergasted at the beginning
it's like i just
like where do you start with this this
such a fundamental problem and
by the way it's not just a problem with
bungie this is a problem with every
single games of service game
and actually bungie is crazy it's crazy
that bungie is one of the
better you know better they're one of
the better companies to deal with this
they're dealing with this better than
most companies they're pushing out
quality content more often and a lot of
a lot of games as a service
either they're not at this level of
content like yes
i mean you could look at any game that
paul tassie's related with because he
does all kinds of service games
all of them are below destiny avengers
does way less you know all the other
guys do
a gentian impact is way less uh but then
the games that are games as a service
like battle royales
those are the exception of the rule
because they don't require you to make
more contact
they refresh themselves because they're
pvp focused games so it's just
at the scale that they're doing it it's
really admirable but yeah
i'm one of those guys who doesn't think
that destiny was ever designed to be
played every game
and that bungie developers were
genuinely surprised when people were
like wow
people want destiny to be the only game
that they play and now they're
they're trying to like feed this machine
that will never
be saved it'll never be finished and uh
it's a losing fight that i think that
them even
participating the fight is like them
losing in a way like they're because
because
it's such a losing battle but yeah i
mean i could talk about this for hours
like just this topic alone but yeah my
my feeling on it is that like they're uh
this is just another domino that fell
and i think the way that they executed
it in particular not letting you get
powerful engrams
uh twice not not letting you get the two
chest loops and just as like
now there's another activity that is a
rehash of an activity that's unrewarding
and like how many times have we seen
that in destiny dude
it's just such a problem also yeah uh
it hurts feels bad valid man
yeah uh i don't think i can top that one
so master vlog
can't we out so we'll see you later
yeah see you next week actually i
probably won't because i'm not going to
be high enough i'm going to get squashed
i'm not even going to try it i'm just
going to watch and see i want to see
like a couple of the elite teams then
after that just go see what everything
looks like
but next week we will be getting a new
patch to bring all of this fun craziness
in
and a sandbox update mid-season
sooner than they expected so the world
that travis does like to live in
in pvp is going to be seeing a shift
and a pretty dramatic one to be
completely honest uh they brought in
um trying to get his name just uh chris
proctor so he's the
weapons feature lead and he's going to
give kind of he gives basically a pretty
big breakdown on stuff i'm going to kind
of give the high notes and basically
we'll talk about topic wise
um one i did want to touch on though is
well they're going to talk about 120
hand cannons we're going to talk about
shotguns dead man's tail a couple things
uh
sleeper simulator no cogs excited uh but
they wanted to
touch on specifically first the intended
special weapon rules in pvp
and i wanted to kind of go through each
of these and see i like that i like that
i want to get a
yeah your name from you guys if you
agree that these are the roles that they
should be in
or if there's any wording in here you
don't agree with
so first one sniper rifles engaging at
long range with aiming skill
when not already under fire
oh oh travis travis has an adjustment
flinch lover what's going on here
not under fire like yeah you shouldn't
be shooting back if i shot you in the
face
played halo no scope oh come on
come on it's snapshot come on uh
i know so here's the thing i i just
there are too many weapons that can
flinch you but
and and you know i i play halo so like
that that game
you you get de-scoped if you get shot
where you're in a sniper rifle
but you can still while under fire you
know
kind of move to left and right dodge
around them and then scope in for a
second and shoot at them so
i get what they're saying and maybe
they're saying like if you currently are
getting hit you shouldn't be able to hit
them
yeah that's totally fine okay i i feel
like
you part of the fantasy of a sniper
rifle it
at least to me in video games and
obviously this isn't true of how sniper
rifles are used in real life in real
life you're like laying on the ground
for like an hour right
battlefield sniper rifles what that is
in video in video games
the fantasy is that like somebody's
messing you up and you turn around and
if you have the skill
and speed you can just like zip in and
just take them out right away
and i think listen to halo announced no
scope
that's the halo talking right here
snapshot that's it that's what it says
when you do it
uh yeah like video like video game guns
never function like they do and act like
in halo the the most hilarious thing to
me is that
assault rifles are short-range weapons
and pistols are long-range
long-range rifles
but destiny has stupid stuff like that
too so fair enough
basically he agreed he just want no
scope continue
shotguns engaging at point-blank range
using
skill at movement or positioning to get
close enough to get a one or two hit
elimination
read that one more time engaging at
point-blank range
using skill at movement or positioning
to get close enough to get a one
or two hit elimination
i feel like that's where it should be
also not how shotguns work in real life
right typically just a one shot
yeah i think that or this area is okay
now
fusion rifles engaging at mid-range but
with careful positioning and
pre-charging around cover required for
success
[Music]
one more time i'm gonna go with cog on
that one engaging at mid-range
but with careful positioning and
pre-charging around cover required for
success
i got two thumbs down okay so what would
you
so what would you guys change i like i'm
playing moderator right now
what would you guys change i like this
see what's up um i guess for me with
fusion rifles or
i never had this thought that when i'm
using a fusion rifle
i have to essentially anticipate where
the enemy is going to be around the
corner every single time to be
successful
i feel like fusion rifles you they you
have that room
to where even if you're caught in a gun
fight
already you have a chance of still
succeeding if you have the skill to
place all of your shots yeah
i'm with that i don't like the verbiage
of
a round cover right so basically you're
basically telling me you're implying the
weapon is useless without
any bit of hiding and hide-and-go-seek
play
you know what i mean and i don't i don't
like that verbiage i think that
like i said i mean if the time the kill
on the gun
is that i'm that i'm facing against is
higher then yeah if we're going head to
head then i should die right
but if i move around in opposition right
and i'm able to get all those bolts off
at what is it they're saying mid-range
yeah at mid-range
then hey i should be rewarded too you
know i mean so
it's it's a it's a risk reward because
if you're gonna get
hit if you go head up right i think one
aspect of play is doing the pre-charging
and hiding and being sneaky and doing
yeah that's one
aspect but i don't like that thought
process as the primary way to play
because basically it just makes in my
opinion it just makes
me not use fusion rifles on a one-on-one
fair engagement you know
and then their map structure is weird
not all the maps uh
you know what i'm saying i designed the
setup that way so that that's just me
but
where you got charles i'm curious i'm
curious what you have to do
yeah i um i think that they're
i don't think their statement is true or
sorry i don't think their statement is
wrong
i just don't think that it's the full
story of how fusion rifles are used
because
at least in my case most of the time i'm
using a fusion rifle it's because
some team is just being like cocky apes
and they're like running at me trying to
get that one hit kill
you and i'm using fusion rifles to keep
my distance
backstrap's encountered yeah
that's how i play yeah that's how i said
so i feel like that sentence could be
fine but they would have to add another
sentence to it that says like
you know controlling the battlefield for
people who are trying to make aggressive
approaches
and stuff like that it's it's more like
that than it is about like
recharging because for me i'm not i very
rarely i'm like oh let's just wait
around the school
yeah and yeah i just i don't i don't
play it that way and i think that most
most people i know don't play it that
way but uh i'm hoping that's part of the
story
like travis is saying that we're just
seeing a part of the story that bungie
for whatever reason chose to focus on
i hope that's not where they're trying
to rain all fusion rifles to live in
this space that if you don't play like
this
it's not going to be successful in the
environment yeah
space rifles strong at close to mid
ranges
but of the cost of not being a one-hit
elimination making it possible to be
outplayed by skill for primary users
that's a quick thumbs down by travis
what about you it's it's
close range trace rifles throwing it
close to mid-range this is what it says
yeah that is like that is incredibly
wrong
i've never seen anybody pull you're
telling me somebody's hip firing a trace
rifle
like literally i've never seen that like
to me trace rifles are like
a really bad mid-range weapon and even
worse
far-ranged weapon and i've never seen
them close range so i truly don't know
where trace rifles are supposed to be in
the meta but if that's their idea
they're
way off like they have a lot of
reworking to do you're absolutely right
with close
i got to be honest trace rifles
that i've seen in pvp right now
especially um no minimum control doesn't
count
true but it's laser tag that's different
what's the what's the
osiris one the um trials trials of
osiris
the trace the one that's uh exotic
that's um
damn it that has the circle bubble when
it gets
let you reload come on chad solar one
yeah yeah
yeah that one is good in pvp it's just
it's
the ammo economy is bad purposely it is
very dominant and engaging time to kill
is low trust me what i'm telling you
but i'm with travis that yeah not close
range
did i say that you should switch that
maybe bro i was getting
getting handled with a dude that was
used i was like
damn traces are because this is the
season they brought the um the economy
so you can have it yep yeah yeah yeah
trust me y'all it's
it's criminally underrated try it
it it's it's not it it's something but i
will say yeah
just a close part you know are they
close range do they use it at close
range
never using that close range no you're
absolutely right not not close range
mid-range
you know i'm saying mid to mid-range
that's what they were doing it and then
the spiciest
topic of all not really not even close
but we'll have some fun
grenade launchers useful for weakening
an opponent
getting damage around corners with
bounces or getting a one-hit elimination
with a direct impact
at the cost of projectile travel time
and being in a bad place if you miss
your shot
with the single round magazine i
actually agree with this one
i don't think that that's how they work
now but i think that is a description of
how they should work
i actually gave a thumbs up on that one
because that was the one i actually care
about the most because
granted i crutch on them hard and people
are going to be like noob tube all day
long i mean you can honestly like
uh you listen to fire and range and
drewski absolutely hates him some people
are okay with everybody has different
opinions on how they are
um some people like oh it's not a
skilled weapon i'm like
it depends there was a point i was
terrible with him
and i like i've actually put time in now
i was like i told you i was going
through a sponge
like lobbing grenades at snipers out
there
and that was what was working for me
because i felt comfortable doing that
now is it something you can learn and
once your comp now is the splash
cleanup that one that's one thing i've
heard some people like the direct hit if
you can hit a direct hit
yeah if a grenade hits me in the chest
doesn't matter what type it is probably
should kill me
still kind of hate the grenades don't do
that that you throw but if a grenade
hits me and explodes
fair some people were saying if the
splash damage was less
that could be a thing so then the
cleanup would be a bit so it's not just
like a one tap cleanup
that might be more of a thing to balance
them a little bit i'll be curious how
that goes but overall i like the way
it's worded
because yeah i mean if you can you know
plan a corner it's just like hey i'm
gonna bounce a corner it's your
way to hopefully push someone back maybe
from a corner
working one but it's like you only get
two unless you're just rolling in ammo
so it depends
scavengers are a thing special ammo
that's a different story but overall
kind of like the description
shotguns are very dominant in pvp by any
measure shocking
uh and don't allow for much counter play
with primary weapons
basically they'll go through with the
ability to quickly follow up
rising in importance we expect faster
firing shotguns to eat into aggressive
shotguns
in dominance and basically what they
said they want to
they want shotguns to excel in a
narrower niche than they currently do
so that this change aims to retain the
reliability of one hit
elimination but at closer range and push
them to slightly
rangier current than they currently are
at getting two hit eliminations
so that makes sense to everybody
it's weird basically they state the
reduced shotgun
fallout did a hilarious graphic too so
um
the damage fall-off minimum starts
sooner so like your full damage
will start getting less at a shorter
distance but
the maximum damage falloff basically
when it goes to shooting peanuts at the
person
is two meters farther so if you can use
as you talked about a rapid fire that
you're hoping for
the two tap of a rapid fire has
potential farther
but the single shot will need to be
closer
that's generally their goal with
shotguns uh aggressive frame shotgun
cone angle they get into slug shotguns
are unaffected
but i know you're kind of excited to
talk about the shotgun so cog you're
first
thoughts about these changes are you are
is this something you're excited about
hopeful i was um you know
i was listen this is a forced change in
the meta this is definitely a force
chain this is
this is you know phil winter's life
you know the homies all you know the
homies you know the aggressive shotgun
homies you don't say that they're gonna
pull one out like
they are trying to reign in the one-hit
kill potential of these weapons we know
the hotter apes do they
listen i'm i exact you raise your head
right
yeah like i've turned into it i step
travis i literally stopped fighting it i
hate that style of gameplay but it was
so effective
i'm like i am being putting myself at
disadvantage i have this
guy roll fair fellaini just lie or
whatever right why am i not using it
because i
see the one-hit kill potential and at
range with the shot package so
this is what that is you know what and
also what i think what's happening is
which we're gonna hit and allude to is
um they're gonna touch
our special ammo economy but before i
get into that
strictly on the shotguns this is now
we're going to force the meta
into precision slug and rapid fire
right precision slugs have always been
good it just required
a little bit of skill with your shafts
and you know whatever your precision
likes to get that head shot
to get the instant kill and rapid fires
is just that
that two burst of whatever you're using
either iklo shotgun or whatever
rabbit it just wasn't enough to stop
the apes the apes were gonna run down on
you the slides the movements
all that once they close the distance
unless you're doing what travis is
saying and you're backing up and all
this other stuff
and voopin you really and even if you
did like there's going to be that time
you know how this travis both players
turn a blind quarter if the apes already
ready you're done
there's nothing you can do right so
that's what this
is now it's like they're just going to
make it where it's only those type of
scenarios when you're really on top of
each other
where that's going to be effective and
they're going to take the other weapons
and put that in consideration
surprisingly i don't have too much of a
problem with
i understand the frustration i
understand people with the god rolls
aggressive they're going to be mad
they're not going to like this at all
but i don't have too much of a problem
only because
it's such a dominant thing it was the
only
way to win in my opinion so i'm okay
with this one
overall you know something but i'm
curious to see what you guys are your
experience
you know with especially yeah i'm sorry
uh prince
uh this and uh another change that's
mentioned later
yeah it's fine i got one i got worlds
you're good yeah
had me had me going it's about time
i feel like pritchett sorry continue
yeah it's about time because like you
said it's just
it doesn't matter what level of play i
feel like within pvp
this style of play of running and
gunning aping with shotgun was just
everywhere and with this change i
actually beforehand um
during uh season of the chosen i started
experimenting with
chaperone in crucible so with slugs
coming more
and rapid fire coming more into the
limelight with the change i'll
definitely be interested in seeing
how it evolves but yeah i am i'm glad
for this change i'm i'm ready for it to
happen
and uh props to bungie of finally
cracking down the whip on some of these
uh weapons are out of control
i got i got to speak to him i see his
soul leaving his body i see the ape
dying inside killing his baby i need to
know how he feels about this
caesar from planet of the apes here uh
very upset
what's happening to my people um oh my
god
yeah are we doing how are we doing
yeah so i i actually didn't really play
an ape style for most of destiny but
you know once shotguns became like
unavoidable i just like gave in and
you know i you find yourself screaming
oh [ __ ] every time you get killed by
a shotgun until
you do it and then you kill like five
people
what what yeah you know it's like the
best feeling ever
so um i've been i've been on the uh
fun end of the ape equation for uh
quite a while and um i will say this
though
it's not changing for me because oh an
ape though i may be
i am a chaperone duality ape so
you're trouble no matter which way you
look at you this this actually
makes my job better because now i don't
have to compete with low skill people
who are just using spray and pray
shotguns uh i if i turn a corner and
they have a shotgun and it takes them
two shots i can
line up a shot and get a head shot so
i'm i'm
not real in any danger here i think it's
a good change i think that
um precision shotguns now you have an
even more important role and it allows
anybody who still wants to continue to
use a shotgun like me just has to hone
that skill
um so yeah i think this is a net good uh
i'm not gonna miss low-skilled players
ending up with more kills than they
should have just because they've
uh gotten exploit or you know whatever
so uh yeah i'm gonna stick with
uh i was gonna say duality has actually
been my go-to because it's
multi-functional use but
now perhaps i gotta give props though i
love the duality reference that they
people don't understand that weapon is
super
powerful and effective in the right
hands continue but
now it's now it's not going to be caught
because it's mean
it's it's main advantage was that it had
that dual ability i mean it's in the
name
and so now it's dual it's it's a uh it's
non-scoped
uh ability is going to take two shots
you're never going to use that
if uh with it as valuable as ammo is
especially
with it not no longer being a one-hit
kill so i think chaperone
being the better precision weapon yeah
and always been it's it's just gonna
which which is unfortunate because
chaperone doesn't have a uh a catalyst
and duality does so i'm sort of waiting
for
they get they have to give chaperone a
catalyst or at least uh
i i guess we'll talk later on in the
tour talk about you have another
solution for it
shout out real quick to d flawless for
the raid thank you very much for joining
us sir
if you guys listen to this on audio or
video go find d
flawless tick tock twitch twitter it
doesn't matter go listen to that man
he's got some great stuff
the legend salute man shout out to the
raid too the other
yeah i was going to say the other major
change which is probably going to be
probably the bigger shake up
aggressive 120 hand cannons were
adjusted in season the splicer
but this didn't make enough of a
difference we believe that they're still
too rangy and benefit way too much from
a small damage buff
it's a bit tricky because they're now
not too much different from their
pre-beyond light form but people have
latched onto their ease of two tapping
our ease of two and two tapping
potential since beyond light
with this change we expect other
primaries to become viable where
previously 128 their lunch
adaptive hand cannons pulses scouts
autos while allowing 120s to keep the
advantage of hard-hitting peak and shoot
so they're reducing precision damage
multiplier from 1.8
to 1.6 basically it prevents rampage
level one from two tapping
reduced aim assist minimum falloff
distance by one to two meters depending
on the range stat
and reduce damage minimum falloffs
they're gonna be a little less range
doesn't sound like a ton but the two tap
potential is going to be much
much harder to get a hold of which is
hopefully better if you you should at
least
you know three tapping feels like a
reasonable time to kill does make them a
little more but it is probably going to
make stuff like 140s a lot more potent
um who's got the beef who's got the
craziest thoughts on this one because
this is going to really
hand cannons are everywhere especially
120s which are big so what do you guys
think is going to be
any up and comers obviously we know 120s
are going to get shake up i know
travis had like six thumbs up over here
so what do you
what do you got first sir i'll go to you
yeah uh
this is great man i i think uh yeah so
i'm on the opposite end of this where
like i don't typically use hand cannons
because i use shotguns and they don't
they don't go together super well so at
least in my play style so
uh i get i get killed by a lot of hand
cannons where i'm just like god dude
that guy was so far away and he too
tapped me like
possible and it's very frustrating so um
yeah i think this is a great change
hopefully there will be more medium and
long range because i'm okay getting into
a long range you know
scout rifle or pulse match but if i'm
using a pulse rifle and somebody kills
me with a hand cannon i'm like
come on man that's right say
yes yeah so i i think just hand cans
have always been too uh
dominant in um in destiny even when i
used them i i used them
like back in the shadow keep days i was
just a hand cannon main all my loadouts
were for that
uh but i have i haven't used it in a
while it's sort of just more annoying to
me in crucible lately so
this is awesome yeah but i i hope that
this time it actually changes things
yeah i mean look i'm jumping right quick
um i think that it is
small i like this change that's my only
issue i liked when 120s got buffed don't
get me wrong i always felt 120 that
hard-hitting
archetype needed love the issue i had is
exactly what travis said like it did not
feel right
when i met i call it range three and
five father
right and i'm getting out dueled by a
hand cannon with this crazy aim assist
and it hits hard like that to me was the
double winning
it's it's bad enough that the aim system
but it hits like a truck
so now you got the two-tap aspect with
rampage you know
that was also a thing that you know was
really a problem for me you know what
i'm saying but it's still not gonna be
completely
over because um kill clip exists you
know say so people who get your clip
will have but i don't get too mad with
that one
you know my main thing was just like i
said the aim assist because
you can't hit that hard from that far
that's the double whammy you know what
i'm saying so i'm cool with this i i
have no problem with this i would not be
crying or ever
i feel sorry for the igneous gang
igneous gang i know how y'all feel i
know
i know out yeah falling out you're gonna
have to just get into a little closer
range
let's go scouts and pulses and snipers
live out there now you get your behind
in range two to one and that mean you
cool and i ain't no problem okay
that's fine mr nelson what about you sir
uh yeah yeah i i'm with cog on this that
for when it comes to pvp
uh i'm mainly using pulses shout out to
messenger
sometimes i i tip dip my toe into the
dmt scale i'm not gonna lie
only good scout that that feels good in
my hands
um when it comes to crucible basically a
hand cannon with a long barrel
yeah but uh yeah it just never felt
right that i'm at that long range
against the hand cannon and i'm just
just getting shook then getting dead all
of a sudden trying to duel
a hand cannon from across the map so i'm
glad of this change
i think that uh again that initial nerf
to 120s was
not enough they were still dominant
wherever you saw them
hopefully with this change we'll see
the meta kind of even out with those
longer range weapons
um also with again 140s will be coming
back more into the limelight
so yeah positives on my front with that
no doubt
uh i agree you guys basically covered
everything it's like it's
i just in my head what a hand cannon
always feels like a revolver and it's
like i don't know how the hell you hit
me that accurately from that far away
i'm sorry it just doesn't seem right
desert eagles not that accurate from
like 50 meters away don't think so
how would you so that's just my thoughts
uh couple changes to perks
drop mag can no longer roll on new drops
of weapons we'll have functionality
change later so drop mag is going to get
a fix
a mix up later on not sure what's going
on there they're kind of vague
pulse monitor fixed issue where handling
bonus was no longer applied rewind
rounds
fix an issue where the perk would not
trigger if the last shot missed
so that's fixed reservoir burst we've
seen the last complaints uh they're
trying to beef up reservoir bursts
basically give it more of a feel
yeah please exotic tuning
it again exotic tuning
dead man's tail is dominant on mouse and
keyboard
what that's new huh receives frequent
critical feedback from players
in crucible and is strong but not
worrying so on controller
so we're keeping the fast firing in hip
but we believe is
uh we keep we're keeping the fast firing
in hip which we believe is key to the
field of the weapon
but with this change it will no longer
have ads levels of
damage fall off while hip firing so
basically they're removing the hip fire
damage falloff scaler
was 1.8 x to match zoom amos's cone with
the hipfire scaler was
1.5 now it's 1.2 i know we're getting
into some technical stuff guys basically
the aim assist is going to be a lot
lower
and the damage fall off is going to be
greater at hipfire
to sum it up good things all around on
my book you guys agree hopefully
they're trying not to kill it but i
think they're trying to make the hip
fire halfway across the map with the
scout rifle
not quite be as good as it as it is
right now a little too dominant
yeah i've i've been using dead man's
tail on comp and it's a little too
powerful
and i play a controller it's just a
little too powerful right i heard on my
mk is it's it's beastly
yeah i like how how they want it to rain
a little bit but not
i hit it too hard for the people using
it on controller like i'm also on
control as well but
yeah the changes are warranted i'll just
be on my mouse and keyboard over here
it's fine
cry more
ah sleeper simulate
didn't receive any custom tuning when we
updated linear fusion rifles so this one
is just for mr cognito
the total buff is now 16.5 percents
compared to the 15 linear effusions
received if you got that catalyst
if you got sleeper simulant pull it out
of the vault i'm glad i said it out of
the vault right
uh cog what do you got to say it's a
great day fellas
thank you for all your support your
prayers
brother this was a long day since then
since the evil that evil gay mole gambit
came and killed my baby and they've been
knocking it down but we
fought we fought for this moment and
then they tried to
dupe us they told they lied to us
they told us last season lydia fusions
would get at a cross buff
and behold sleeper gang was left in the
cold
with a with a nerf with a nerf how
dare they after i bled tears in that
terrible raid of spire of stars i got
that
awful drop that i had to do all these
awful things to get the catalyst
but the day has arrived the guard tier
weapon
i still say better than galahore sleep
for civilians
sleeping with the goddamn gears together
pastor is preaching today
is back oh it feels good i can't wait
to shoot atheon in the chest when he
does his little move he's does his dance
step
i'll be ready with my critical shot it's
a great day boys it's a great day and
they recognize me getting a total buff
and
it could be single shot dps weapon and
remember if you got the catalyst with it
with the scavengers
boy get the sleepers out voice good day
man it's a good day i cut out i have it
ready i have it in my dim
i have it ready to go as
soon as this is why i'm logging in on
tuesday
this is it baby sleepy let's go
yeah just the emotion cosmetics i
figured cog took that one i had to just
let him have it but yeah he's been
waiting
this is this nope tears you know many
twelves i could play
all right so that covers most of what's
going on in the sandbox but when it
comes to the big issues that have been
screaming in the sandbox itself
especially for pvp that does feel like
it's going to be a big shift so i do
hope we get to see
some changes some feel i'll be curious
kind of where people are you know
chatting about things on twitter but
they also mention stuff in the near
future because this is a mid-season
patch
most of this typically would have been
coming at the start of season 15
we're at this point where we get like an
early patch
and now we get some stuff that they're
hoping to shoot for in season 15. so
we have more changes than usual for a
season coming in
uh season 15 some as follow-ups to the
above so some other tweaks
others that were too large for
mid-season but here's a preview of some
big changes
fusion rifles d flawless you're still in
here this one's for you we've been
waiting to tackle
sub family differentiation for a while
so our planning on a large
rework of fusion rifles changes to mods
perks and custom tuning to most exotic
fusion rifles
is vex a fusion rifle let's say yes
[Music]
i'm wondering i've been wondering i've
been waiting for them to address that
for a while yeah
vex did not land great at
all so it needs some love real quickly
i'm very interested and excited i don't
get too excited but
they want to tackle the subfamily
differentiation
like rapid adaptive i'm very impressed
yeah yeah i want to see how they go with
that i like that they're at least
mentioning that yeah that they may look
at them so
in that level uh my baby breach load
grenade launchers
with the above shotgun changes we expect
other special weapons to increase in
union
usage and believe grenade launchers have
the potential to become
more frustrating to play against as they
become slightly more common
so we're planning a small change that
specifically touches priming and
cleaning up targets
which i mean that's kind of what they
said that's the whole if
you know you can do a proximity
detonation near somebody and do 90
of the damage you got to look at them
wrong and they die and i was like that i
kind of you know
a grenade still explodes near you but i
mean we're guardians we have shields i
guess we'll see how that
turns out i understand it though i get
that um
scout rifles and hand cannons and pve uh
criminal i'm sorry
we are mentioning scout rifles in pve
i'm honestly floored this is on the
table players have wanted these weapons
to be a bit more efficient in pve for
some time we found that the minor
enemies in high-end content take too
many shots to kill with these weapons
thank you oh my gosh how long has this
something we've been waiting can't sit
in the bat and plink away too long and
then finally like
man it's about to i'm sitting on a um
what's that raid um posterity i got this
great posterity role
and it's i'm just like why doesn't this
thing hit harder man
same thing like there's so many weapons
hand cannons and scouts that you like
i should be struggling with the red bars
to clean them up
i was even going through like last
sector there was just like goblins and
i'm shooting them with my night watch
and i'm like
one and this is 13 10 by the way one two
three like five shots on a goblin i'm
like
i agree it still should be hitting you a
little harder anyway
um so that's big machine guns in pve
we've been waiting on this too
machine guns right now outside of
xenophage are useless in most things
you go in there and you're like oh let
me melt a champion if you got xenophage
you should switch yeah all right xeno's
only good because it's a sniper
yeah right here uh through play testing
and player feedback
i'm surprised it took this long we found
they're not doing their job as intended
well enough we're planning for a
noticeable
change in season 15. i want them to give
them the rocket launcher treatment let's
do it
boys can we get hopeful can we get can
we get hopeful for thunderlord can we go
get some
dude i'd love to see thunder i'd love to
pull out thunderlord come back
it was so great with the remember it was
multi-functional because you had the
boss dps effect too
with the extra joy i missed the lord
rain
that was a fun meta for me yeah i would
love to see it come back yeah i was like
if you pull that eenie machine gun
that's not zeno on like say a champion
right now
it's not even gonna happen it's so not
worth it
special ammo economy particularly in pvp
while the above changes the shotguns
could help tone down the aggressive
frames a bit we've got a couple of small
changes planned that should reduce the
amount of special ammo
floating around to a degree and have
further changes in mind in case they're
not enough people if they stay alive
long enough with scavengers have
pretty much infinite ammo i mean yeah
it's
a bit ridiculous uh here's the time to
pour one out
anarchy has done too much too well
for too long without even counting the
boost it got this season which is due to
the sweet grenade launcher artifact mods
so we're making changes that make it
great at a couple rolls rather than
being the jack of all
it says grenade launchers but it may as
well be jack of all heavy weapons to be
completely honest
uh are you guys surprised at all what do
you think they're going to do
to it is the other question fair enough
that's my response to this fair enough i
assume they'll just they'll just lower
the damage output
across the board but yeah fair enough it
was fun while it lasted it's one of
those things like it had a
long run yeah it was like spin to win or
the uh
you know the other um exotic sword they
introduced with
beyond light uh we we all knew this was
coming so
but france uh so i have the
the salty spicy take for this and
where i this is the voice that i read
this in
um anarchy has done too much
too well for too many
years i was excited for this change for
the one reason
i have uh not set aside the time to
grind my spoils so
i don't actually have anarchy
weirdly enough weirdly enough i'm still
sitting at like
200 spoils because i haven't grinded
enough
even when doing a little bit of the
templar farm just
haven't set aside a time to just grind
spoils so
when i read this change i'm like okay i
finally won't feel like the odd kid out
when it's great
time when it's high-end bullets
what are those reaching clear yeah yeah
yeah
for people enjoying it like again i
understand that the change is warranted
and i was never that salty because you
know it's pve content we're all winning
at the end of the day
yeah um yeah it'll be interesting to see
what they do to it
yeah i mean i i make it quick i'm with
tribe like
it was a good run boys i mean we we
can't complain and my main issue was
not the nerf that i always feel the i
think we all know we have mason
who said it or somebody said it it's the
you get so much
ammo maybe it was clyde we were talking
you get 26 or something
yeah oh you get i feel like i never run
out of anarchy
ever between the scavenger perk and then
breach it clear
that unstoppable grenade this season boy
with that artifact etiquette's what it
looks like
it's time boys it was a good run what
did you say
uh yeah i mean it was due honestly it's
one of those that i really haven't used
that much
intentionally because i'm when i make
videos and stuff like that specifically
i'm like i know not everybody has
anarchy if i'm literally like
if you have it use it it's fantastic
right here arkburn if you use
you know bridge and clear it's crushing
stuff right now but for those of you who
don't i don't use exotics or supers in
my
like lost sector guides that i've been
doing because i'm like i want everybody
to be able to like use whatever fun
tools you have this is the base that you
can get it done with
so i haven't honestly been using it that
much i know how powerful it is and
honestly just seeing everybody go
through and be like
pink pink and hide yeah
like so it's just it's a very passive
weapon
yes um and i think they want people to
be a little bit more active and honestly
i'm surprised this lasted this long
as much as as much work as it does as
much as you can put
two shots of it and then move over to
something else like
you know it was double anarchy and then
snipers or however it's been
we're finally getting to a point to
where it's you know they're trying to
make a big shift and anarchy out of the
heavy slot
will definitely move some things around
final one clear
great season to go out on yeah i was
like
it got its heyday for sure i do feel bad
for people like destin who did that raid
100 oh god
yes and now it's going to get nerfed so
on your next episode you got to make
sure you bring that up
just to just throw it out i will i will
no doubt very curious to see what they
do with it but yeah it's time
the final one the final one has got me
intrigued too we wanted to give players
more
reasons to use exotic primary weapons in
high-end pve content and that's
we just got done talking about anarchy
like anarchy xenophage
why would you use anything those are
deuce death singer like or death bringer
can't even remember now
heavy weapons and then the exotic
version of those really really sets them
apart
typically that it's really hard to even
consider a primary you could use an
energy much less like you know you've
got fighting lion or other ones like but
to use like
hawkmoon's the only one i know that'll
pump out some damage if you get your
crits
what i mean am i going to go use um
what's the one with cosmology
am i going to use graviton in a no
reach the fact that that's even a
possible option for priming i mean it's
an exotic and you only get one
it needs to be exotic yeah they need to
do the same thing to armor but that's
another whole podcast
oh yeah now this this is the one that
treat me the most because i felt this
way
for a long time in destiny i feel like
it there's really
less benefit to use any exotic primary
in high-end content you know what i'm
saying and let the only one that i
remember
that was like okay i can use this you
know effective was probably outbreak
perfected with the catalyst because you
get a little bit extra dps with the
nanites and stuff like that
on single target that you know bosses so
that's my thing i just feel like they
really need
to they got to figure out something with
boss dps on these um
these exotics because there's no reason
i mean with deathbringer anarchy like
you said all those zeno why would i take
that off to put on sunshine you don't
say like
in a raid or you know what i'm saying
like you're not gonna do it for the most
part
unless it's very specific scenarios
where it's a burn
and something has a nice cleanup effect
or whatever the very specific scenarios
where you will use it yes but for the
most part exotic primaries outside of
the cars that's going by
there's exotic primaries that um that
that you have like
dino fey i mean casino i mean what's the
grenade launcher the one that drops to
taking bloop
what's the one the horde with that with
a horse
um outbreak perfected what other one
would you really
use in high-end content i can't really
think of that many half of those are
energy
special anyway especially yeah yeah
we are very very curious about this
i mean there's nothing what they do yeah
it was like it's
that's one of the biggest ones i'm very
curious about so yeah you have a lot of
potential in primaries but most of them
don't get touched
yes sir so other than that
we've got some patch note previews and
stuff you guys can look through there
are some expunge issues that have been
there they're working on fixing those
because i can't tell you how many of
those floating blocks i've fallen
through
that don't work um but other than that
they basically state uh they'll keep a
close eye on special weapons and they'll
make more adjustments how they're gonna
go
they said um they're gonna have the
patch at the start of season
15 and anything from this current
mid-season thing
might have a mid season 15 patch to kind
of
see where things are at or make more
adjustments as they're going through
but they are working on the sandbox um
as substantially as they can it seems
for now with the mid-season then season
15 and then mid season 15
but we're gonna be at least seeing some
adjustments balancing always kind of a
moving target
but uh as we kind of wrap up
that's kind of the end of the twab and
before we head out too much i wanted to
kind of see if there's anything else you
guys
needed to touch on it has been a two and
a half hour show so i'm gonna keep you
guys too long but uh
anything else i'm missing not this in
destiny
yeah you got it you know a very the
distant
future stuff um very interesting so you
want to make adjustments
to certain things with the special
weapon and the economy i thought that
was interesting
i thought the catalyst stuff was
interesting underused um a catalyst and
then
you know addressing the the fact that if
you don't have if a weapon doesn't have
a catalyst
it loses the the ability to create orbs
they're working on that if there's going
to be some type of mass work some type
of a
a mechanic to address because that's a
big deal that's a big deal so i like
that they mention that so the future
looks bright as far as the sandbox stuff
i did
i agree for the most part with most of
the stuff i can't really complain
you know i thought a lot of these
changes good i'm really excited to jump
in the pvp in the metal on tuesday
that's why it's hard like i got to do
banning because i want the light and i
want to at least attempt
a couple of the um master vlog stuff but
as far as the the sandbox and the
changing i want to see how these things
how the man is going to play out i'm
very excited about that so yeah that's
what i got what about you guys
travis here you're chomping at the bit
over there
ditto champing at the bit actually i'm
sorry
um i think that's twice i've got a
saying wrong so i'm learning
yeah i keep it's just so such a weird
thing about our relationship
uh yeah i was nip it in the bud and then
champing at the bit
uh okay so uh yeah i i kind of agree
with uh with everything cog said more or
less like i
i think they have some i have some
questions about their definitions for
weapon roles and how they're going to be
developing those but
uh in in so far as the changes they're
making right now i think
it's largely good most of them are pvp
focused which i think
has the most issues and then the few
areas where pve could use
help like probably making anarchy less
dominant making scout rifles and hand
cannons more
are really good but yeah this is an
awesome meaty twab uh i
i think this is probably the
the seasonal update that we were going
to get if
the witch queen came out when it was
supposed to um and so now
you know we're just getting it early
because that was delayed so uh
it definitely feels like uh the size of
a patch you would expect before an
expansion so
i'm curious to see what additional stuff
they'll change before which queen
actually probably goes out
yeah good point
um pvp changes are are exciting
very welcome interested to see how they
are next week
for the future stuff like cog i'm very
excited for their changes to exotic
weapons
and giving them a way to make orbs for
exotics that don't have a catalyst there
are some exotic
weapons exotic primaries that i like to
run just for the fun of it but i'm not
getting the benefit of making orbs
from them or any additional added perks
that would come with the catalyst
also with that excited to see how they
change up for these exotic primaries are
underused
i think a lot of these guns are very
iconic and they have some interesting
stories
uh behind them but they're just heavily
underutilized
because you have so many better options
out there so very much looking forward
to that
i would agree when you guys kind of
covered everything it's
these are always big to see kind of it's
always nice to see where everything
settles
once all these patch notes hit what's
gonna you know what's gonna pop up in
the pvp meta if shotguns and stuff come
down when some of these things in the f
what exotics should i like look forward
to i mean
sky burner's oath is a joke or cause you
know um
i just forgot the pulse rifle again uh
it's like certain ones like that i'm
like man it hasn't literally been three
or four years since i've used those
give like to give me a reason to even
think about using those i'm like
could be fun so again the catalyst is a
way to beef some of those up
but again as paul had been asking for
forever i think when he's like at least
let me make orbs
so that's coming too so there's some
nice quality and just like yeah not to
force anarchy on everybody will be a
good thing as well so overall
a lot of positive stuff in there i know
it's a lot to kind of
work through in this episode but
generally positive things overall i
think
generally and just be curious to see you
know what comes out of the meta next
yeah i want to know what the new
channel's going to rise up yep i'm very
curious
as we wrap up episode number 156
uh first off i want to shout out travis
for co-hosting with us glad to share the
campfire with you sir happy to have you
here
thank you very much see how often we get
to see your face on here
always a pleasure though um but before
we go like
uh ty mr prince delson um it has been a
pleasure having you on sir
great to see your um star wars helmet
just
shining right there next to you couldn't
have asked for another co-host to see
that one so
the timing was amazing to have you on it
was pretty perfect um
but at this point the floor is kind of
yours like where do people find you what
do you like doing what random hobby you
got going on
it's just the floor is yours tell people
the best places to find see
interact with you and all of the above
uh
first of all um travis lord cognito
ibontis
thank you so much for having me around
the campfire it was it was very great
doing that destiny talk with you all uh
very humbling i appreciate it so much
and for where people can find me a
random hobby in
kendo right now so if y'all want to
cross swords um
but uh you can find me at twitch.tv
neil igneil um otherwise you can find me
prince delos on twitter with the twitter
handle of prince igneel
and whenever i get back to doing youtube
videos i'm prince dallas on youtube
uh most of the time you can catch me
writing up articles on lordsgaming.net
i'm ryan for there but yeah so twitter
uh twitch when i'm streaming streaming
once a week over there
and lords of gaming.net where you're
gonna be finding me mainly throughout my
week
nice travis you got anything exciting
which i'm sure you can't discuss be like
what are you working on
it's nda yeah so i i'm working on a
exclusive ign preview that will be out
later this month
awesome uh ryan and i are putting that
together so i can't talk about it but
it's
a game i'm very excited about and until
then you can
uh find my most recent reviews on
ign.com i recently reviewed
dungeons and dragons dark alliance which
i love
which i gave a 4 out of 10.
bad yeah don't play that game unless
you're playing it free on
on game pass and and uh i'll say save
yourself from some heartache
i do want to really just 60 seconds say
cog and ebontus you guys both know about
this but i recently overcame a personal
struggle with my um external hard drives
and uh i thought this was gonna be
serious for
this actually relates to you guys so i i
finally got out of
the the walls that were closing in on me
on my 18
terabyte maximum storage i am now at
running at 34 terabytes
which means i'll be able to have
thousands of more games installed on my
xbox
but i was thinking to myself travis what
are you going to do
with your old external hard drives and
so i've decided
cog and e i'm going to ship you guys
an 8 terabyte external hard drive wow
your guys's house
since i don't need them anymore because
no one
should have to uninstall their games
wow baby let's go man thank you
that's that's it that's crazy
and also i still can't believe you have
34 terabytes of xbox space
right baby that has to be some kind of a
kind of record somewhere for it is
actually the maximum amount you can
have on any xbox well it's the it's it's
like the xbox what is it made up of
teddy says 36 36 no so 36
is if you were if because some storage
uh
hard drives don't they don't let you
save on all of the space so it's
it comes out to about 34 terabytes when
all said and done but
the the bits all that stuff yep yeah
inside the xbox you have one terabyte
and then the one terabyte external ssd
card
you can get and then you're allowed to
have two standard spinning disk hard
drives
and previously the maximum was each of
those drives could only be eight
terabytes so i bought
two eight drives and i was running it
and then teddy and i did some research
and we found out that
like without telling anybody they
increased that to double so now you can
have two
16 years old so i have two
16 terabyte external drives uh and then
i had you know these
these uh drives lighting around and i
figured
i should thank my my friends at uh the
last word for
for giving me a home after uh after fire
team chat
is uh not happening as often as it did
so there you go
i'll get your addresses after this yeah
yeah
i could always use the caddy the mule
yeah where's where's my games it's in
that thing
so much space you're running out of
house in the fire what are you grabbing
i got to grab the safe in this thing
it's got everything oh that's well thank
you very much man but yeah definitely
pleasure to have you on
always enjoy the rants and the opinions
because they're always entertaining to
listen to
um but before we go too far i wanted to
shout out my co-host
of a long time sir lord cognito
uh i'm gonna let you tell what it is but
i honestly can say i was
just amazingly proud of the news that
got announced this week for
lordcognito on twitter he is joining
a huge name in the world of xbox uh he's
put in a hell of a lot of work for iron
lord's podcast they have an amazing
thing going
and they're really infectious over there
and he's been between a lot of different
podcasts and
he got called up to the big leagues
officially this week i kind of knew a
little before
so where cognito can they find you
going forward sir yeah man thank you
e i appreciate that um yeah i'm going to
be
the new co-host of defining duke last
stand media and um
shout out to colin shout out to maddie
shout out to the whole team
you know they can also again i would be
remiss if i don't shout out carrick acg
for a previous co-host of uh defining
duke
who uh moved on he's got things going on
and you know the opportunity presented
itself so
yeah man i mean it was just i really
i guess when you grind so long and you
have your head down always about what's
the next thing what's the next thing how
do i improve or what's going on
i don't really have my head up to kind
of uh appreciate
you know what what what was going on so
far and the love
man y'all gave me a lot of love you boy
your boy teared up a little
bit because it was i was overwhelming i
you don't know how things are going to
be received
i think and um to see everybody just
like yo
god you know it was it was overwhelming
it felt good it felt good and um
just it's been a warm welcome it's been
a lot of love it's been
a warm reception obviously the first
episode we've recorded already
you know patreons it's up now but the um
i think it will be released to the
public on sunday and then i have a
defining duke ultimate that you guys get
to see which is kind of just me
on their platform and they're calling it
getting to know [ __ ]
so it's kind of funny and i i i have
some uh mailbox
mailbag questions and stuff like that
but i want to thank everybody because
you know the destiny community
the entire xbox community just gaming in
general and
and some of my heroes to see a tweet
from ryan mccaffrey
someone i really respect you know
someone who's been doing for a while and
say hey
you know cog that was the choice i
wanted for you guys
it hit hard man it hit hard it was you
boy your boy tiered up so i was just
like thank you thank every e thank you i
saw your comments travis i saw you
always teasing me about how any
broadcast support
dude it just keeps growing it's amazing
uh
you had you had calling on your show uh
the iron lord podcast and
you thought you were interviewing him
but he was interviewing you
it was a pilot somebody said that danno
says it's now
supposed to be your grace lord cognito
but a joke me and kyle have was from a
you know from a lord to a duke
you know i was i was researching in
theology i was like oh yeah duke is
hiding
upgraded but now he finally passed you
travis
i know my
my lordship is just sitting here uh
without any sort of promotion
i gotta thank you sir you actually did
it
your boy did it no you got it oh my god
officially oh lord i did it i did one
oh yeah bro when you when i did your
intro and i researched you and i
realized
you were legit
running around with an official lord
title and i
am not a lawyer oh man where's your
lordship is it
this is scotland it's a scholar yeah
they got it which uh what
which uh which uh province are you on
i'll get you the prophet's details a
little bit after the show
he literally just two up to you in one
pocket
i had to be with my
i'm man real lord now and i'm a duke and
i've been on more ign podcasts than you
and i'm best friends with colin i was
like jesus dude
i get it you win okay my show just got
cancelled
you inspired me bro i thought that was
the coolest thing i'm like yo
he is a lord in real life and i've never
had i gotta get this
i gotta get going uh we'll have to so
there's like clubs for lord so now
oh let's do limericks together i'll
teach you the rules
there's let's go uh scottish i need
pictures of you two and kids legally
if you get cog i don't know if you're
married or not but if you know that if
you get
if you get married they have to change
their name to the lady
uh that has to get added to their name
there's like all these rules your kids
have to be lords and ladies and
when you die they inherit your estate
which i assume is like
one square foot or whatever you did to
get it yeah
it's gonna be uh you know look at teddy
black jacket
[Laughter]
listen i had to do it you were an
inspiration brother that's amazing
congratulations
again i have so much to congratulate you
all to you man but now dude it's been
it's been a fun week
you know appreciate the support again
just for the record nothing is changing
otherwise iron lord podcast lords of
gabriel.net continues
of course when my man e that last
word continues man but thank you all
chat everybody for love
fun week geek dreams continuing and uh
just continue to work hard and do uh
great things man but
thank you for the love yeah
on that one uh i'm just imantus
everywhere pretty simple
i can't follow any of this so i mean i
am
the advanced gg he bought it yes use
code
cody code because i am now bigger
he's pushing that powder guys
it's best in small lines uh through the
nose no i'm just kidding
[Laughter]
partnership gone i do not recommend the
dry scoop i'll be honest i have done
that just for entertainment value it'll
be
it's not the way to go uh one of those
uh what are those pixie
pixie stick on the thing and then you
dip it oh fun day
right you could do fun dip but yeah
um yeah shout out to advanced gg cody
bontes please don't hate me
uh but no i've actually jamming on their
sour watermelon it's fan
i love watermelon is like a summer fruit
i can sit there and like cut up a
watermelon eat half of it in like a
sitting if i wanted to
um so it's just one of those fruits
yeah and then yes they did actually drop
a new flavor for
chill if you're looking for a little cbd
you can get a pina colada flavor now
they dropped that today
so you're looking for a little cbd
relaxation and hydration in your life
you can do it that way
um yeah i'm still always i have like
strawberry limited and watermelon are
kind of my two go-betweens i'm kind of
mixing up with everything else so
projectile but that is all i got you
guys it has been an amazing show we're
gonna go raid
above actually he's gonna be our guest
here in a few weeks
uh a couple of weeks actually so go hang
out with him next week we've got sarah
very small app coming on
she's a kind of she does a whole lot of
pvp so we'll be picking the brain of a
pvp lady
next week so tune in but for now we're
gonna go raid them right after the show
but for this week
episode number 156 we wrap it up in epic
lordly
fashion thank you tai it has been an
absolute pleasure
thank you baby yoda groku
has been here spoiler alert to those of
you guys uh it's been a fun podcast chat
you guys have been amazing
thank you so much so for episode number
156
always a pleasure and a delight thank
you guys go follow all of these people
it has been